- Smell my jeans, Garnt, smell my jeans.
- Get that shit out of my face, man.
- That's like musky shit.
- That's dripping
with your fucking sweat,
Connor, is that what you're
talking about when you mean drip?
- God, you don't know
how many people would pay
for that experience.
- Smell my jeans, bro.
- Smell Connor's jeans.
- Give a sniff.
- Get that shit out of my face, man.
- Smell his jeans.
(upbeat music)
- Hey guys, welcome to another episode
of Trash Taste podcast,
I'm your boy, I'm not your boy.
I am the boy with the boys.
(laughter)
- Fucking stumbled
through that, didn't you?
- Is that the worst
intro you've ever done?
- No, no, my all my
intros are the worst one.
- I could feel, I could
feel like your mind,
just like starting up as
you're saying that sentence.
It was just like...
- Yeah.
I'm like, you know, those
really old lawn mowers
your dad has, where you have to do
(revving)
like five times until
it finally gets started.
That's my brain right now.
- So how are you guy's week's been?
- I just had an absolutely
fucking ordeal this morning.
- What? (laughs)
- Yeah, so, okay,
so this is like fucking what now?
Like volume eight of Gaijin
versus Japanese Bank, right?
(Joey laughs)
I think we're, I think we're
like at that volume now.
- Thriller and Manilla,
Gaijin versus bank.
- "The bank strikes back"
And I mean, like, to me, like, now,
like, going to a Japanese bank
is kind of like going to the dentist now
'cause like I do anything I can
to put it off, right?
- I like my dentist actually.
- Really?
- Yeah, I really,
it's been great here, the
bank's way, far worse.
I would rather have like
an anal rectal cavity,
whatever that is, opposed
to going to the bank.
- An anal rectal cavity at the dentist?
(Garnt laughs)
- At the dentist, I would rather her use
that drill on my ass.
- Let me see your teeth.
- I would rather her do
anything experimental.
- Honestly, honestly,
I agree because like,
I've been putting off going
to the bank for ages, right?
Because I've needed to send
money abroad to back home.
- Okay.
- Because right now,
I'm helping my parents pay for
the mortgage of their house
so they can retire and
have a nice comfy life.
- Good Asian son right there.
- Flexing right there.
- Just being a good Asian son.
As you do, so, I mean,
I've been doing this
for like basically since I started YouTube
but since I moved to
Japan, obviously a lot,
most of my money is now in
my Japanese bank account
and I've known for a while
that I've needed, that I was going to need
to transfer money into
my British bank account.
- [Joey] Of course, of course.
- I was just dreading
this, right, as you do.
As you do with any
Japanese bank experience.
What I didn't realize was
that I was going to have
like the biggest ordeal I've
had yet in the Japanese bank.
- Oh, God.
- So I mean like,
so I'm just like, okay,
I booked the appointment
because you can, you
can't do anything online,
as we've said, on call.
- God forbid you can be you
in the 21st century.
- [Joey] Yeah, right?
- Yeah, so I turn up as usual and normally
when we turn up to the bank,
they normally have one guy
who works there that
acts as an interpreter
because he speaks English
and Japanese, right?
- [Joey] Right, right.
- So he wasn't there today.
So...
- So they just let you
do the appointment, did they know?
- Yeah, they knew it was me, they knew.
So you know the guy, you normally-
- Yeah, they weren't
gonna be like, uh, Garnt.
Yeah, that sounds Japanese (laughs)
- So, so it was the same woman
that handles our accounts.
- Right.
- But the interpreter, the
guy who speaks English,
wasn't there this time.
- [Joey] Okay.
- So I'm just like, "Okay, this is gonna,
this is gonna like, this is gonna put my
(speaks Japanese) to the test, right?
This is gonna, this is going to stretch it
to the fucking limits, right?"
because, because I mean,
thankfully I have been, you know,
practicing as much as I can.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Especially my listening skills.
- But this is gonna,
this was going to stretch
it to the limit, so-
- Like bank hard mode.
- Yeah.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
This was bank like fucking
Doom impossible mode or whatever.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
So, we start the process and we take it,
we take inventory
and I bring all my usual stuff, right?
I've got my hunker,
got my bank book,
got my bank card,
got everything.
- Fully prepped.
- Yeah, fully prepped.
- [Joey] All right.
- I'm like, I'm experienced.
- Yeah.
- I'm a fucking Japanese bank war veteran.
(Joey laughs)
I know what the fuck I need to do
at Japanese banks, right?
So I'm just like-
- I know what happens in the battlefield.
- So I'm like, great.
So we start the process, I'm like,
"Can I transfer money
to my British bank account please?
Or transfer money overseas?"
and then she starts explaining
to me the process and I'm like,
"Fucking hell, okay, like, I understand,
like, 70% of what you're saying"
So I'm like, I'm like, great,
I'm following what she's saying,
I'm like, "You know what? maybe, maybe,
maybe this, maybe this
will be a smooth process"
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So I put in my name,
put in my address
and everything I need to do
and then we get to the actual transfer
part of it,
the actual transferring
money to an overseas bank.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And so she asks me
about the bank and I say,
"Oh, it's a British bank. It's Barclays,
it's my account"
And then she says,
and here's where,
here's where my Japanese got tested.
She said something, right?
And I heard,
I heard "transfer" and I heard "purpose"
and I heard "connection" right?
- [Joey] Okay.
- So in my mind-
- Stitch it all together.
- No, no, no 'cause this-
- Yeah, that's how you do it.
- 'Cause that's just how you do it.
So I heard those words,
so I stitched the meaning
of the words to be
"what was the purpose of the transfer?"
- [Joey] Right, right, right.
- Right? 'Cause that's-
- Naturally.
- That's naturally what I assume.
- Yeah.
- So I was like, oh great,
the purpose of my transfer.
- "My friend in Nigeria.
A prince actually."
- Yeah.
- So I tried to explain in the
most broken Japanese I can,
the purpose of my transfer
is just to transfer money
to myself in England.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I was like, British bank account
in England, my British
bank account in England,
transferring money to that.
- Yeah.
- And she was like, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no
and re-explains and she re-explains it
and now I'm just like, okay,
so how do I explain to her
that I'm going to be paying
a mortgage for my parents
in England and I'm just
like, fucking hell.
This is-
- I struggle
to spell mortgage in English, I guess.
- I'm just like, I'm just like-
- I was like, wait,
mortgage has a T in it?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(laughter)
- And I'm just like, (speaking Japanese).
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I'm just like,
that's the most I can come up with.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Which is basically-
- Better than I would have done, honestly.
- Which is basically, for the purposes
of my parents, I'm paying for-
- Paying for their house.
Right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And she was like, no, no, no, no, no
and then we just like try
to brokenly communicate
to each other and then she just,
and then she whips out
the Google translate
and I'm just like-
- Yeah, I was about to say,
why don't you whip this out?
- And I'm just like,
okay, here we go, here we go.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then she Google translates it
and she's just like,
and the translation is,
"Do you have any evidence
that you have a connection
to the purpose, to the
person you're transferring to
for the purpose of this transfer?"
And I'm just like,
"What? It's--
It's me!"
- "It's literally me"
- "It's literally...
(group laughs)
"It's me! are we, like,
is this a fucking circus
we're running here?
Like, what's, what's going on?
Like how can I prove
that I have a connection to myself?"
Right?
- It's like,
if I were you, I would have been like,
"So, how many fucking Garnt Mayatapos
do you know in the world?"
- Yeah.
- Tell me.
- This is the thing
that I was dreading about Japan,
is that nothing's ever good enough.
- No, no.
- It's like, no.
I want to see a passport of other you.
- Yes, because, because
to a Japanese person,
sending money to yourself overseas,
it's just a concept that
they don't understand.
It's like, "Why?"
- Yeah.
So the first thing I say was like,
"Oh, I mean, my names are identical
isn't that enough proof?"
And she was like, "No, no, no.
It's because in Japanese bank,
your first name comes second
and your surname comes first,
so it's Manitapo Garnt"
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then in my British
bank account, Barclays,
it's Garnt Manitapo
(Joey laughs)
and because the names don't match,
they obviously assume-
- Different person.
- They obviously assume
I'm like a duel citizen,
like I'm fucking Jason Bourne
with five different identities.
- He whips out the pistol bag.
What, which one, it's actually Russian.
- Yeah.
- So I'm just like,
what do I need?
- Yeah.
- And she was like, "I
dunno" I'm just like,
and she was just like,
"I dunno, do you have any bills?"
And I'm like,
"I don't have any bills
'Cause I live in Japan now,
but will like a bank statement do?"
And she was just like,
"Yeah, sure. A bank statement will do"
and I'm just like,
"Do I have to print it out?"
and she says, "Yes, it
has to be printed out"
- Of course you do.
- And scanned to us and I'm just like,
"Well, shit because obviously,
thanks-
- "Can I borrow your printer?"
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Thankfully,
with British banks,
I can access my statements
very conveniently
on my phone.
- But you can't just do this.
- And on any,
on any electronic device
and I'm just like, "Okay, how can,
okay, this is where my
engineering problem skills
like commence" Because I, first up,
first thing I asked her
is like, "How, like how much like,
can I go to the Konbini?
to print off my,
to print off my statement" right?
And she says, "Sure, how
much time would that take?"
And I asked "How much time
is this appointment booked for?"
And she says "I have an hour" All right?
and the appointment's booked for an hour,
so I have an hour
time slot, because I am not fucking going,
I am not coming back to the bank,
just for the purpose of this transfer
and I'm not missing out
on this appointment,
so I'm like "Fucking,
I'm doing this right
now" and I'm just like,
oh, "I'll be right back, I'm going to go
to the Konbini, I'm going
to print out my stuff"
- "To print out
what I could have showed you digitally"
- Yeah.
- I could've just done this.
- I could have sent it
to you in an email.
- Email.
- Yeah.
- You know?
- Exactly, so I-
- Like, "Do you have a
fax? You can fax it to us"
- So I rush off to the Konbini
and then I realized that,
so there's, so every Konbini
has a printer, right?
And there's only a few ways
to connect to that printer.
- Oh, yeah.
- One way- (laughs)
- I know, I know.
- You see where I'm going with this.
One way is via phone
and the other way is via USB stick.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So I was just like,
"Okay, great, maybe, I got it on my phone.
So I'll just connect via my phone" so I-
- You think you will.
(Garnt laughs)
- So that to me was like my first
my first option to problem
solve this fucking issue
that shouldn't be an issue, right?
So I tried to download the app
to connect to the printer.
The app's not available internationally.
- Of course.
- I have,
my Google Play store
is still linked to my UK account.
Luckily, luckily
that wasn't too big of an issue
'cause I have a Japanese account as well
for this exact purpose of
downloading Japanese apps.
- Right.
- So obviously,
I download the app and
everything is in Japanese.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And obviously,
my nihongo is not jouzu
enough to figure out Japanese.
(Garnt laughs)
Yeah, my nihongo was not good enough
to figure out this app.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So what I did is, I have
a second phone, right?
- And you translate it.
(Joey laughs)
- And this second phone
is my UK phone, so--
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So I have like this old UK phone,
it's an iPhone five,
which is like my phone
before I upgraded to this new phone now.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Which is, the only
purpose for that phone
is just so I have a
UK SIM card so I can phone home,
or if any UK people want to phone me.
So I'm fucking like,
I'm fucking on my phone
with another phone Googling,
Google translating my phone
with another phone (laughs)
- I've done that.
- And I'm just looking
like a little fucking clown in the Konbini
being like.
So I'm there for about
four, 10, 15 minutes
trying to get this phone
to connect to the printer.
It just does not want to connect.
- [Joey] No, no.
- Fucking,
I don't know what is
going on with the app,
I don't even think it was the language.
I just think it was the app.
- No, I've tried, I've tried
using that app and I
tried for like an hour.
It just doesn't connect.
- This is why I just always
carry around the USB stick.
- Yeah, right? Same, same.
- You just never know when
you need to print something.
- Yeah.
- So I'm like,
"Fuck, this isn't going to work, okay"
15 minutes have passed,
the time is ticking.
I've only got like, at this point,
I've only got half an hour
left of the appointment
and I also still need to fill
out the rest of the form.
So I've got another 15 minutes at most.
I'm just like, "Okay, I
need to find another way.
Thankfully, I remember I
brought my laptop with me.
Great.
- Good stuff.
- So I can and I have a USB stick as well
in my bag.
So I'm just like, "Great,
I just need internet"
so unfortunately
with Japanese sims, you can't
tether internet (laughs)
- No, it's like, it's like an option
you have to pay for.
- Yeah, exactly, exactly
so I'm just like fucking Googling
"Where is the nearest internet Hotwire,
internet hotspot?"
So I look for coffee shops, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So I'm like brilliant,
there's a fucking coffee-
- Or like McDonald's or something.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's just like everything
you do, there's another thing.
(laughter)
- It's like side quest to
complete the side quest.
- "I'm gonna have to order
a drink at Starbucks"
- Brilliant, there's a Tully's coffee shop
like right, you know,
a block down from me.
So I fucking sprint to this coffee shop.
I don't want to buy a coffee
'cause that's just adding more time on.
So I'm like outside the coffee shop
and I'm just like fucking,
I'm just like fucking Watchdogs, you know?
(Joey and Connor laugh)
I like, I take out my laptop
in the middle of the,
in the middle of the street,
I take out my laptop,
open it, fucking connect to the wifi.
- It's so ghetto.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah, it's like a scene of Watchdogs
or something where I'm just like-
- Turning off the traffic lights.
- I'm hacking-
- Into the main frame.
- I'm hacking the system,
so I like download,
download my, download my statement,
put it in my USB stick,
run back to the fucking Konbini,
then I can finally
print off the statement.
Then I'm just like,
and by then 20 minutes have passed,
I fucking run back, run back to the bank
and I'm just like,
"Do I have enough time to
complete this transfer?"
And she's like, yes, yes,
we'll make enough time to like,
thank fucking God.
Okay.
So I hand her the statement,
right?
And she's like, "Okay,
great, we can use this"
And then, so we start
filling out the rest of the form.
So she asked me for my
British account number
and account details.
And so I whip out my
Barclay's debit cards.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And she looks at it
and she goes,
"Oh, we could have just used that"
and I'm just like--
(laughter)
"Oh my God.
I am literally about to scream right now"
(laughter)
- And you know, if you ever ask a bank,
like person, like, being like,
"Why didn't you tell me that before?"
Then they'll just be like,
"Well, you didn't ask"
- (mumbles) Pandora's fucking box.
- Yeah, it's like "Cool,
thank you for giving me all the options"
- Was there a transfer
limit that you could do?
- There wasn't a transfer
limit thankfully enough.
But the transfer itself cost $80,
which is just like, fucking Jesus Christ.
- So I think the reason
why Japanese banks,
'cause I read up on this before
'cause I had to help Aki do
the exact same thing, right?
So like send money back home
for her parents and like, yeah,
I have to go through this,
obviously I didn't have the problem
with the Google translate thing.
So I got it done in one go.
- Yeah.
- But I was just like,
"Jesus Christ, like why is this just
such an arbitrary process, like,
it shouldn't take this long"
and then I saw like a thing being like,
oh it's because Japan has, like,
run into like a lot of, like,
money laundering issues and I'm like,
"I don't know if anyone can be bothered
to money launder if it takes
that fucking long to do it"
(Garnt laughs)
- Honestly, it's probably
a deterrent at this point,
like, why would you money
launder in Japan when-
- When it takes like a full
day to process, I'm like,
"I can't be fucked to
money launder any more.
I'll just be a law-abiding citizen"
- Honestly, it's probably easier
to like abide by the law
than be a money launder at that point.
- I feel like money
laundering is not an issue
that is an every day issue
for the consumer at the bank.
- [Joey] Right?
- I feel like
we should really be looking
at these massive billion dollar transfers
that are done from the Cayman Islands.
- I guarantee it was probably
like, it happened maybe like
once or twice and then obviously
every Japanese company,
when something bad happens
once or twice, they get
super paranoid about it
and they're like, "Guys, we have to stop
this money laundering
crisis, it is unstoppable.
Make the process as bullshit as possible
so that no one can be bothered to do it"
- Is that really the reason why?
'Cause I've noticed that
like anything payment wise,
Japan is very easy to send money to,
but very difficult to get it out of.
And I've just wondered too, I just assumed
that was like Japanese
government being like,
"Yeah, we want money to stay here"
- I mean, that's probably
also a thing as well.
I'm sure the money laundering thing
is just like a farse,
like a public thing that they just say
but I think guaranteed.
- Yeah, it's for safety.
That's why we don't like it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- "We don't want you breaking any laws"
- Have you ever like sent,
have you ever been scammed
via like any money scheme
or something like that?
'Cause like I remember like the-
- Like phone scams and stuff like that?
- No, just like been scammed
with like transferring money
and then you never got it back
or something like that
'cause I remember when I was,
the only time I've sent
money, that was just like,
I could, just got completely scammed
and I rightly so got
scammed because this was
when I was trying to buy a
fake ID when I was under age.
(Garnt and Connor laugh)
- Well, yeah, mean-
- I mean,
I totally deserved it.
- Instant karma compilation.
- No it is, I absolutely
deserved it but I,
'cause like I remember, you know,
back when you're a UK teen, you know,
the person who had the fake
ID was the cool guy, right?
- Yeah, he was the king.
- He was the fucking king
because could buy the drinks, you know,
he could buy the alcohol, he
whips out the realistic looking
fake ID and it's not just like the,
obviously like really like
obviously fake student ID.
- Yeah.
- Like you can buy
from like $5 from like some guy.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So I was just like, how did,
so I knew a guy who had
a fake ID, so I was like,
"How did you get it?"
and he tells me this, you know,
really dodgy fucking
website and I'm just like-
- Of course.
- And I'm just like,
"Am I desperate enough
to carry the risk of trying
to purchase this ID?"
- He says
as he was downloading Tor.
(laughter)
- 'Cause this is how I-
- It isn't Amazon.
- 'Cause this is how I realized
'cause you couldn't pay by
card with this website, right?
- Oh God, Bitcoin?
- No, no, no, this is far,
this was way before Bitcoin,
you had to transfer
via Western Union.
- Oh my God.
- Literally, anything with that is a scam.
Anything that uses, I'm pretty
sure that's how Western Union
makes money, through scams.
- Which is why I asked, right?
Because I obviously,
'cause I had never heard
of fucking Western Union
before, I was just like,
what the fuck is Western Union?
- I only know about it from scams.
- Yeah, same, same, yeah.
- Now I do know about it
from scams
and so, because I tried, I was like,
I tried sending this, I was like,
how do I send money via Western union?
Is that a bank, is that
like some Nigerian bank
or something like, like I've
never heard of this before
and like I, three blind this fake ID,
because at that point I was a dumb kid
and I was stupid enough to just trudge-
- You were desperate enough.
- I was stupid
and desperate enough to
just try anything to like
get a fake ID.
- Mans was desperate.
- Huh?
- Yeah, so I was like, sure, I'll try
this Western Union stuff,
maybe it will work out.
- Famous last words.
- And then I find out
that you can only send like
Western Union transfers
at not even banks but like
certain corner shops in the UK.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Right?
It's not even anything efficient.
It's like the most dodgiest
places you can send money
and these are the only
and I'm just like, "Maybe it'll work out,
maybe it'll work out"
- That's like the equivalent
of being like, you can buy this with cash
but we have to meet in
an alleyway somewhere.
It can't be on the open road.
- And I think I would have
preferred to meet someone in the alleyway
'cause at least there would
be like another person.
I could communicate with, right?
- How much was it?
- Huh?
- It was like 30 pounds.
(Connor laughs)
I mean, that was a lot for
me as a 16 year old kid
or whatever all right?
- Oh yeah, of course.
- Like what was I trying
to, moral of the story is,
don't buy fake ID kids, it's not worth it.
- Yeah and also-
- Of course it's not worth it
'cause you didn't fucking get it.
- Yeah.
- Don't be stupid like me.
- The moment you see Western
Union as well, turn around,
like don't even bother with that shit.
I know Japan actually has like
a lot of scams because like,
you know how the population
here is very old, right?
Like the majority of
them, so there's a lot of
like phone scams that happen.
- Yeah, I've heard about that.
- And the most famous,
like variety of phone scams
is they called (speaks
Japanese) which means,
"The Me, Me Scam" so
basically how it works
is a guy calls up like an old,
you know, granddad or a grandfather
who like they do back
research to see like,
"Do they have grandchildren?
Do they have a son
or a daughter?" and they call them up,
and they go,
"Oh, it's me, it's me"
like, posing as their son or daughter
being like, "Oh, it's me, it's me.
I need help, you know, can you get me
like X amount of money"
- Right.
- So on and so forth
and so many old people
fall for it.
- Everyone's so, you know-
- Yeah.
- Polite in this country.
- Yeah, right, it's insane how much,
like my grandma almost
fell for it one time.
I remember.
- [Connor] Oh, wow.
- Like when I was quite
young, luckily she didn't
but like yeah, there was, they asked
for like absurd amounts
of money, like, you know,
upwards of like hundreds
and thousands of dollars.
- [Garnt] Jesus.
- [Connor] Jesus.
- Just to be like, "Yeah,
can you transfer it like tomorrow?
I'm like desperately need
it, I just lost my job"
blah, blah, blah, all that kind of stuff.
Every year, dude, like
old people fall for it.
- "I need $100,000, I lost my job"
- Yeah, I lost my job.
- "I need
to order a Domino's pizza in Japan.
(Joey laughs)
I need a hundred thousand dollars"
- "I need to buy out
all the Domino's stocks"
- I need one large
Domino's pizza from Japan.
- $100,000 (laughs)
- It's $100,000 (laughs)
There's also the, I think actually,
I remember I watched videos
about people who became homeless
in Japan and apparently one of the scams
that makes people
homeless a lot of the time
is guarantor scams,
so like people ask
people to be like guarantors on their rent
and then they just run off.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then they have to
pay the guarantor thing
and they lose a shit ton of money.
- Yeah.
- Because most people
can't afford to pay double rent.
- Yeah.
- Which is a shitty thing, isn't it?
- Not to mention
the key money and all that.
- Oh my God.
That's a scam in itself.
- Key money is a scam
in and of itself.
- That's just a scam
everyone's agreed to, I think.
- Yeah, I think so.
- At what point
does it stop being a scam
and does it just like-
- Tradition is the biggest scam of all.
- I just don't understand
the point of that.
Just being like, oh yes, here's
an extra month worth of rent
as a thank you for letting
this peasant stay in your abode
and it's like, I'm fucking
paying rent every month.
Are you not happy with the rent money?
- I'm already paying you
money to stay in your place
and you want to pay me
extra money to be thankful
that I'm paying you money, I'm like, why?
- Am I not thankful enough for the rent?
Why should I be thankful to pay you money?
- So yeah, in Japan, you have to pay one
to two months rent upfront.
- Yeah, depending, depending.
Some places you don't have to.
- In my place you have to.
- And it's not a deposit
because you know.
- No.
- Yeah, deposits, like
everyone always asks,
is it a deposit?
- No.
- There's a deposit.
- Yeah.
- Which like comes back
to you after you move out
but then there's key money,
which just does not return.
- Yeah.
- It's literally just like,
just like a-
- It's just a bribe.
That's all it is.
(laughter)
It's to be like, "You'll
let me stay, right?"
- It's a legal bribe.
It's like, "You'll let me stay, right?
Here's some money"
- You know,
at least they don't in,
Japan, they have to deal
with like Microsoft scams and
like the Indian call centers.
- Oh yeah, true, oh my
God, can you imagine that?
- I think it's the reason
we get them so much
'cause Indian people can speak English.
- Yeah, that's true, that's true.
- But I remember when I-
- The moment Indians
can start speaking Japanese, it's over.
(laughter)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, right, I remember-
- It's like the moment
where actual companies
move their call centers from India
to let like literally any
other country it's over
but it's always in India,
that's what makes it
so hard sometimes.
- Yeah, God.
- Yeah, everywhere you'd call in the UK,
it was always an Indian call center.
Especially with internet.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- The amount
of times I'd call up and I'm like,
I don't even know if I'm talking to a scam
'cause the service is
so shit, you could film.
- It's always like internet
and banking as well, right?
- Yeah.
- That's always great,
to have a-
- Which are
the two big things.
- Yeah, that's what was great,
to have a dad who worked in IT.
'Cause I'd never needed to call them.
I'd just be like, "Father, help me please"
- Help me.
- "I know you're not Indian"
When I first worked with BookWalker.
I was doing a promotion with them
and it was actually on one of my videos
where I prank called scammers.
- [Joey] Oh yeah, yeah.
- And this is where I learned
that they don't have them in Japan
because I'd made this video, right?
Where I basically just called up scammers
and I just kept promoting
BookWalker to them.
Just kept doing it, kept doing it
and then I would like do a super cut
of like the funniest
moments and they would
get really pissed off and
I would be like Microsoft
and I would just be
like, I would just start
playing "The Price is Right" music to them
and just start basically doing a pitch.
(Joey laughs)
And just piss them off
and then whenever they blocked my number,
I'd make a new number
and I called them again.
And so I filmed it and it was great.
It was this really funny bit,
it was like two minutes long
and it was just great of me
and it was great promotion
because I was-
- Yeah.
I mean, that series was
doing really well for you.
- It was literally just me
doing ad reads for two minutes
to Indians and call centers and yeah
and then I sent it off to BookWalker
and I was like, "Oh God,
they might not like it"
and then they were like,
"Okay, it looks that's good.
Will we get in trouble with
Microsoft for doing this?"
(laughter)
- And I was like-
- The truth comes out.
Microsoft backing up scammers.
- No, it was 'cause
when we called them up, they
were obviously pretending
to be Microsoft.
- Yeah, of course, of course.
- So BookWalker is like,
"Oh, is Microsoft okay
with you doing this?"
(laughter)
- How dare you harass their employees?
- "Shit, do we need approval
from Microsoft about this?"
- I was like, "What? No, no,
you know what this is, right?
It's like, yeah, it's a scam, you know?
They call you up, tell
you your PC is broken"
They're like, "No way, that's a thing?"
- That's a thing.
- I was like, yeah, yeah.
I think it was too Maylene, actually.
- [Man] You know when
we call you Microsoft,
you know who's going to answer you first?
Cortana's going to answer you first.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, exactly.
- [Maylene] I knew it was
fake but I had to make sure.
- Oh yeah, it's even worse
because Maylene's American.
Maylene should have known this.
- [Maylene] I needed
to have written proof.
(laughter)
(cross talk)
- Maylene said she needed written proof
that it was a scam.
(laughter)
- "Excuse me, can you give me approval?"
- "Can you sign if you are
actually scamming me right now?
I'm not sure."
- Only in Japan
do you need-
- It's like, promise-
- Written proof from scammers
that you're being scammed.
- "Do you promise you won't scam me?"
"I promise I won't scam you" scams you.
- [Man] It's an agreement.
- Oh my God.
- "Do I have your word, scammer?"
- "Do I have your word?"
- "I can trust you, right, scammer?"
- "Do you have a hanko
stamp, can I get a hanko
proving you're not a-"
- My God.
Yeah, that is true, actually,
now that I think about it.
We don't have anything like that in Japan.
- To be honest, you're right
because think about it.
Even if Maylene says that,
she joked saying proof, right?
What's stopping a Japanese
company from saying, "Oh,
we're providing tech support,
they get the Hanko stamp"
That Japanese governments,
they start calling up people
saying, hi, we're Microsoft,
they probably wouldn't
get shut down for a while.
- Probably not.
- 'Cause even if the report gets filed,
the Japanese government
will take five fucking years
to analyze the case and
decide that it's a scam.
- And by then they would've
fucking dipped out.
- Yeah and then they'll have
ten new networks and companies.
- I hope none of the
Indian scammers see this.
- They're like, "Write that down!
Write that down, write that down!"
(laughter)
- Like "Gentlemen, we are expanding"
- "Dave knows nihongo
get him in, get him in.
He knows Keiko, they'll
surely fall for it"
- "Who's seen anime here,
who's watched anime?"
- I've been getting
into like the, you know,
the YouTube channels that really
look into the Indian scammers.
Like I think, is it Jim Browning?
- Yeah.
- Is that his name?
- I'm a big fan of them all.
- Yeah, I really love
what Jim Browning does and I dunno what,
like I dunno some of the other people,
as well, some of the people who actually
just phone them back up as well
and just really troll them.
I remember I saw one guy
who got an Indian scammer
so fucking angry that he
was literally shouting
on the phone.
- Jesus.
- Well, have you watched like,
yeah Kitboga, have you watched Kitboga?
He does ones where he does like,
what's the inverse speed
runs, I guess, slow run.
- Slow runs, yeah.
- Where he tries to keep them
on the phone for as long as possible.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I swear,
he on average gets it
like four or five hours.
- Holy shit.
- Yeah.
- And just wastes their time.
- He's far too good
at sounding like an old grandma.
- Yeah, yeah.
- An old American grandma.
- He's too good at that.
- He uses a filter
but he also like, he
does a really good job.
- Yeah.
- And he's got the mannerisms
down perfectly 'cause
he just does it all day.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So he's there
pretending to be an old
grandma for like six hours
on Twitch, it's insane.
- [Man] He works with a
voice coach, apparently.
- Oh really, oh my God.
- That's someone dedicated
to their craft, right there.
- They will get
like nine hours, though, on a call.
- Fucking hell, reverse speed run.
- Yeah and then at the
end, the reveal is so great
'cause you could just hear
like how fucking annoyed
the person,
this scammer just gets so fucking angry,
if you're not fast enough.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You hear some of them
where they're like,
"No, got to warm up now.
Get the Google Play card
now, now you dumb bitch"
like shouting at them, like "Wow,
this is some good customer service.
This is still better than
like Virgin media, I think"
(laughter)
- Yeah 'cause like what
clocked me onto to that,
to be honest, that was
like, it was recommended
that I got recommended just a random clip.
I've just, An Indian guy like shouting
at full fucking volume.
- Oh yeah.
You get a lot of that.
- Just like,
"Why are you so dumb?
Why are you so stupid?
Why are you doing that?"
and I'm just like,
"What the fuck man?"
- Yeah, you like,
click the wrong thing.
- Yeah.
- It's like traumatizing
for these older people.
- Yeah, I bet, Jesus Christ.
- Like someone could
murder my mother and I don't
think I'd be as angry as that.
- Right, right, right?
- Like Jesus Christ.
What the hell, man?
(laughter)
- There's some really
good Jim Browning ones
where he like gets their
like passport information.
- Yeah.
- On their like PC
and he like shows it to them.
- Yeah.
- It's really fucking good.
- Go on.
- Scare the shit out of them.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's good.
Check out Jim Browning
like if you ever want
to fall down a rabbit hole and just wonder
what is actually on the other side
of whoever like phones up, phones you up
and tries to scam people.
- Yeah.
I mean, for every one of those people
that's calling them back and
fucking with them, it saves,
you know, one person's money and time.
- Yeah, I mean, if anyone
deserves to be fucked with,
it's scammers.
- It's scammers, right?
- Yeah because even if
you you're quite savvy
with this stuff, you're unlikely to,
if you hear an Indian accent
calling you and telling you,
"Hey, you need to pay
X money to Microsoft"
You're probably not
gonna fall for it, right?
But that's because we know.
- Yeah.
- But also the older people-
- The older generation
have no idea, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I have a distinct memory
from when I was like 10
of my mum coming to me
and being like, "You know our friend?
Apparently Microsoft called them up
and said that they have
some of the worst viruses
in the world on their PC"
(Garnt laughs)
and I was like, "Wow, really?"
"Really" and that was all I heard of it.
A week later she comes back, she's like,
"Turns out it was a scam and they lost
and they lost 1000 pounds"
- Holy shit!
- Adjust for inflation,
that's like 10 grand.
- They said that they had the Y2K bug.
(laughter)
- This was around that time, I think.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I know it wasn't actually.
- Yeah.
- I was very, very young
and I just had this weird
memory of being like,
"That's sounds strange"
- "That sounds dumb"
- "Why would Microsoft call you up?
Why wouldn't they just nuke your PC
if there was a problem?"
(Joey laughs)
- The thing
that I've had to teach my parents
is like, there was a period when they just
were not tech savvy at all, I mean,
like they're still not exactly tech savvy
but at least they were not tech
savvy enough to even attempt
to go on the internet and
go on Facebook and stuff.
- Right, right.
- And it was the point
when they started to
take more of an interest
on being online and stuff like that,
that it really was kind of
like stepping on eggshells
when trying to explain to them
that some emails are not real
and some emails are
scams and it's just like,
sometimes when mum just
like, will send me a message
to be like, "Is this,
should I click on this link?
Should I click on that
link?" and like, I don't know
how to properly convey,
which sometimes like,
which emails are legit and
which emails are not legit.
It's kind of like explaining
to someone over the phone,
how to diffuse a bomb sometimes.
- I told my parents, right, I said,
"Even if you get the
email saying your accounts
have been hacked or
anything like that" I said,
I told them and the same
with numbers as well.
'Cause my dad won nearly,
I think he nearly fell
for him a few times and I always told him,
"Just call them back, like call the go.
Like if you get called by your bank,
like go to the bank's website, call them"
- Yeah.
- Immediately.
Don't talk to them.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you know, odds are,
your bank probably isn't
going to call you and if they do,
they'll probably ask you
a bunch of weird stuff.
- Yeah, for like, you know-
- Just call them back.
- Any like social media gets compromised,
quote, unquote from an
email, then just go directly
to the website and check, yes.
Yeah, never fall for that.
- Yeah.
I nearly fucking fell for that,
the Google Ad Sense thing.
- Yeah!
- 'Cause Jim Browning fell for it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I actually
didn't get that email?
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Dude, you're lucky, man.
If Jim Browning fell for it, anyone can.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I saw his video on it,
actually.
- Dude, it is
worryingly convincing.
- But that's the thing,
right, it's like, it's hard
to like convey to your,
you know, your parents
or your grandparents.
- Yeah.
- Like how do I identify
between a scam email and not a scam email
because I feel every
year it's just get like,
that line is getting
narrower and narrower.
- It's getting good, man.
- It's getting too good.
- Yeah.
- Which is why like,
which is why I find it so hard
to explain to them
because sometimes I say,
I have to like second guess myself.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I'm just like,
if I'm second guessing myself
and I literally grew up
on the internet, I work on the internet.
- Yeah.
- How can my parents,
who have little to no knowledge
of internet culture at
all tell the difference?
- Yeah, right?
- And how am I
supposed to convey that through texts
or through phones and be like,
just don't believe any email
you get sent, basically.
- What up lads, it's your
boy, here to let you know
that this episode of Trash Tastes
is sponsored by Girl Cafe Gun.
Girl Cafe Gun is an AIPG game
that integrates TPS combat
and has beautiful visuals and
graphics powered by Life 2D.
Build your dream waifu team by collecting
multiple character cards, use
multiple fighting abilities
and strategies by switching characters
during intense gunfights, do
you want to prove to the world
that you have a more galaxy
brain than (speaking Japanese)?
Then this is definitely
the game for you, my lads.
During the battle,
characters are oversimplified
into Q version, which can satisfy
different preferences of players.
Plus, it's not all guns and fighting.
If you want to run your own virtual cafe,
the games got you covered with
a plethora of customizable
decorations for you to choose
from and different types
of coffee to boot, discover
your own business sense
by satisfying the needs
of your lovely customers.
Not only that, but you can also enjoy
the diverse bonding
system with high fidelity,
social interactions, including
tickling gift-giving,
moment sharing and private messaging.
Yes, you heard me right, boys and girls,
you can tickle your waifu in this game.
I mean, not only do we have
some of the most beautiful
and aesthetic anime
waifus that we have seen
in a long time, but you can God damn
tickle your waifus in this game.
I had to say that again because that's
important information, so if
you'd like to tickle your waifu
and enjoy a great game, then make sure
to check out Girl Cafe
Gun by clicking the link
down in the description below.
And thank you for sponsoring
this episode, back to the show.
I remember the first time
that Maylene messaged me
like to work with BookWalker,
I thought it was a scam.
- Honestly, honestly, I
thought the same thing as well.
I was just like, I was just like,
no way this is real.
- I was like, "Hold on.
Hold on a second, it says Kadokawa"
I'm like, "The Kadokawa? No"
and I swear the first one,
I fucking deleted it immediately,
I was like, "Nah, that's a scam.
Get out of that" and Maylene messages me,
emailed me again after
a week and she's like,
"I don't know if you read my last email,
but we were interested in
working with you and I'm like,
"Did I delete that one?"
- Oh, there was a,
it was a YouTuber who they,
I can't remember which one,
they got like offered a
role to voice an anime.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- By Funimation.
And they thought it was a scam?
- When they publicly announced
that they'd gotten the role.
- Right.
- In the show
and it was just a fake email.
(laughter)
- That's painful.
- Oh my God.
- That was like, I thought-
- That is-
- I don't think I've cringed out of body,
in pain for someone else more in my life.
- I laughed but that was, that
is just a bruh moment, man.
- If I did that shit and
I found out it was a scam,
I would just quit social
media all together.
- I think I would, yeah,
I would just not show my-
- I would just disappear
from the internet, yeah.
- I would not show my
face, also, you know,
generally when you get calls in stuff-
- Yeah, you're not supposed to say, right?
- Yeah, you're not supposed to say, yeah.
- So I guess maybe it was a test.
It was like, "A-ha, no role for you!"
- Gotcha.
- It was like Willy Wonka.
"Ah, you were too
greedy! No role for you!"
- Maybe it was really Funimation
but they just needed to pass the test.
(laughter)
- It's like Indiana
Jones but the holy grail,
it's like, "Ah, you choose grief! No"
- No, because I going back
to the BookWalker email
emails that we first got, I think,
looking back Maylene must've
emailed me way earlier,
before I actually replied
for the first time.
- Yeah.
- And what got me to reply
was meeting you for the first time
and being like, "Oh yeah,
that email from Maylene,
did you get an email
from Maylene as well?"
And that was just like,
"That's not a scam?
That's real, that was
real this entire time?
I've just been ghosting her
and deleting all the emails"
- I remember, I think that,
I think I sent that email
to about like three or four
different family members
just to be like, "Does this look fake?
'Cause I'm really scared
to reply to this shit
and get like a virus 'cause
like, I don't even know"
Luckily it wasn't but yeah, I don't know
if it was the way that like
Maylene wrote the email
or what it was, yes, I'm blaming Maylene.
- Blame Maylene.
(laughter off screen)
- And I think it was just before,
this was before the point
of (speaking Japanese)
where we thought any kind of companies
like would contact us.
- Yeah
because before that, like
the biggest complaint,
I had not worked with
any big company, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- It was always like,
you know, like-
- Actually yeah, it was not
a thing back then at all.
- I was still tiny back then as well.
So I was like, nah, no way I
can't, this jump is too high.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- That's way too unrealistic.
- I mean, yeah, arguably
BookWalker kind of like,
paved the way in that way,
I feel like BookWalker
opened up.
- I took the bullet
for everyone.
(laughter)
- I was like, "I'll take it
for the good of the people"
Reply.
- Reply.
- Did you see the YouTube scam, though?
Did you see what like the-
- I saw what it was about
because I think literally every,
all of my other friends got that email,
including you guys and
yeah, so I was scared.
I was sifting through my email
as well and I didn't get one.
- So essentially what happened was,
is that I got an email from
a Google email that said,
oh, it was, the message was sent like,
"Oh, you have a duplicate Ad Sense account
and you know, your
channel will be deleted"
and I think that is one
of the rules of Ad Sense
is that if you do actually have
multiple Ad Sense accounts,
you will get banned off Ad Sense.
- Yeah, you can only have
one Ad Sense account.
- And they do send an
email like that as well.
- Yeah and I only have one
Ad Sense account but we,
I had multiple channels, so
maybe I thought, oh my God,
there must be a mix-up
because I'd recently
just had the new channel
and it was kind of a,
but this is often how
scams work though as well.
They prey on very
coincidental circumstances
that have been happening
outside of the scam itself.
You know, like Jim Browning
said in his thing, it's like,
yes and I'm sure you would
just order the product
on Amazon, 10 minutes
later, you get scam email
about Amazon, just pure coincidence
but it happens to play off a little bit.
Right, concerns, so yeah, it's this thing
and the one thing that
was probably the red flag,
which I think did make
me unsure, but again,
I was kind of so worried that I was like,
"Oh, I should just,
I went to hear him out at least"
it was through Google Hangouts,
but it was Google email.
So I was like, okay, well it's a bit weird
because normally they would just,
but then again, I've never had
correspondence through Google
because they're just so
shit at talking to you.
I don't even know how they
would reach out to me.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Because they've done email
in the past but sometimes they haven't.
So I don't really
understand, I think that also
is one of the reasons why
I almost did fall for this
because YouTube is so unclear
on how they reach out to you.
- Yeah, I mean, the only
time I've ever talked
to Google directly-
- Well, I've-
- Through Twitter.
- Yeah, I've spoken to them.
I've never had someone reach out to me.
That's never happened,
so I'm talking to them
and they going through the thing
and they're like, "Oh
yeah, you have a duplicate
Ad Sense account" and I'm like,
"That doesn't sound right.
I don't have the
duplicate Adsense account"
They're kind of like,
"Oh, well you do"
and I'm like, "Okay, well what's the ID
on the Adsense account?"
Adsense accounts have IDs
and he gave me an ID and it was just like,
not even remotely-
- [Joey] Close.
- Close to anything and I was like, "Oh,
okay, well that's weird" and I was like.
"Can you tell me about the account then?
What's the duplication?" and they just
couldn't tell me anything.
- Yeah.
- He was like, "It's all
private, it's all private"
Which would kind of make sense, you know?
- Yeah and I was like, "Okay, well fine.
Fine, all right, well" I was like,
"Can you tell me that
you're a Google employee?
Can you share some proof?"
and he was like, "No"
- And I was like--
- "Because I'm not!"
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
Scooby-doo mask reveal.
- At this point, and then,
what he was trying to do
and he was,
you can make multiple YouTube accounts
under one email.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And so he told me to
make a new YouTube account.
So I did this because I was just curious
to see what the steps he
was telling me to do were.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I knew
none of this was permanent
and it doesn't really matter
if you make a new account,
it doesn't like delete anything.
- Yeah.
- So he told me
to make a new YouTube account and then go
to the YouTube account management page
and then set,
have the new account that I made
takeover the old channel.
Now what this does is that
it deletes all the videos.
- [Joey] Right.
- And delete everything.
- It's basically like a factory reset.
- It kind of just puts it like,
it's just like this channel
and it's gonna like plaster it on top.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Brand new.
Nothing else was here before.
- [Joey] Right.
- That's kind of it.
- It's just a coverup, right?
- Yeah and then, you know,
and it just deletes everything
and then
he was telling me to do that
and so I got to the point where
I clicked on like the,
I wanted to see what the menu was,
to do it and I was
going through the steps.
It was like, "Oh yeah,
it'll delete everything.
Except for like likes
and comments and stuff"
And I'm like "That's weird"
But, and then I was like,
"No, this doesn't seem right.
This seems a little weird"
And so I was like, "Yeah, sorry,
I'm going to contact YouTube myself
'cause I don't trust this at all"
and so I closed the chat,
I contact YouTube and like, "Hey,
is anything wrong
with my accounts?
You know, everything's
going to be deleted?"
He's like, "Nope, that's all good"
And I'm like,
"You're sure?
This guy said it was"
and he's like, "No, no,
that's all good" I was
like, "Oh, okay then,
I guess I'll carry on"
And then I found out it was a big steal,
multiple had fallen for it.
- I mean,
I think the problem was that you just,
even if you wanted to ask an
official person at YouTube,
how, who do you contact?
- I had to like do a web chat
with someone at Google.
- How'd you do that?
Is that possible?
- Yeah.
You can do like a web chat.
- There are real employees at Google?
- I don't know if it's real.
(laughter)
- Probably just like the most advanced AI.
- I think on their
website they have like a,
it's like, "Would you
like to talk to someone?"
It's like a pop up.
- Oh!
- It's one of those services.
- Right, right, right.
- I was chatting to them
and then they would just ask
for information and stuff and yeah,
it was actually surprisingly easy
but you know, that's, I think that was,
that might've been just YouTube.
I don't know, you know, it's all a blur.
- That's the thing, that's the problem.
- It's all shit.
- Everything is so hidden
in secrecy that if someone did
come up to you and was like,
"This is who we are, we're Google,
we're YouTube, you have a
problem" then like most people,
like, especially for
the smaller YouTubers,
they wouldn't know any better
because they'd probably think
to themselves, "Oh, I guess, you know,
no one's really told me
how to contact Google.
I guess this is how they contact you"
- Right.
- And that's probably why
so many people fell for it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I, oh, sorry, did you
have something to say?
- No, no, no, that was it,
Jim Browning fell for it
and a few other big names,
The Spiffing Brit, I think,
fell for it as well.
- Lots of big YouTubers
fell for it.
- It's convincing.
- I mean, I just remembered, I almost fell
for like a scam recently
because my friend's
Facebook account got hacked.
- Right.
- And yeah and so his account
got hacked and so the person
who hacked his account
was like really clever
and sent like a mass message out.
- Yeah, I got it as well.
- Yeah.
Like a mass message out to like,
I think everyone, just everyone
on his contacts list, right,
just saying, "Hey, like,
I've really needed a favor
right now, do you have a minute?"
Right and it was obviously
a bot running it,
'cause if you replied anything else
but I like a predetermined script, right?
Then it would just like block you.
Or it would like just close the message
or something like that,
so a bunch of people,
including Sydney, right,
'cause this was when I actually
got the message while we
were recording Trash Taste.
- Yeah, me too.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So that's why I didn't see the message
but Sidney saw the
message and she was like,
"Yeah, what's going on"
and the message was like,
because it felt like
a natural conversation
because the bot had already predetermined
like a certain conversation
route that people could take.
It ended up being like a
conversation chain that says that,
where he said that he was
locked out of his, I think,
I think like he was locked
out or something or he,
he needed to pay the rent today
and no, he was locked
out of his bank account
and he needed to pay rent.
- Through Western Union.
(laughter)
- Only accepting Western Union.
- No, not Western Union but
he needed to pay his rent
or he was going to get
kicked out or something
and he needed to transfer money
to his landlord.
So he was like, "Can you
please transfer money
to a certain bank
account? And I'll cover it
when I get my bank account back
and I'll pay you interest as well"
And like, so Sydney was phoning
me afterwards being like,
"Yo, yo, yo Garnt, Garnt,
have you seen the message?
Dude, he like, like Mike's
in a lot of trouble.
You gotta, you gotta send money on me"
I was just like, okay,
'cause it came from Sydney
and Sydney sounded so desperate,
so I didn't even read the message.
So I was like,
"Okay, I guess
I got to send the fucking money, right?"
So before I send the money,
thankfully I checked the message
that my mate sent me and
by that point, thankfully,
like I remember seeing the message
and then just suddenly
it just disappeared.
- Right.
- And his account got,
just got deleted.
- Yeah.
It was like, 'cause when I saw it,
like the Facebook was
back to the default icon.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So like I was, that's weird.
- So like I was this close
to just sending him money.
'Cause he's a good mate
and sometimes, you know,
you always got to get your mates' back.
- Yeah, of course.
- And it was really
fucking convincing
'cause I saw the messages
some other people got,
'cause unfortunately,
we've got a pretty good,
pretty big friend group
and unfortunately two people
ended up sending him money.
- Oh, no.
- And I saw
like the conversation chain,
it was genuinely convincing
because it wasn't just
a one message thing.
It was a genuine conversation chain.
- Just a really well-made bot, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, it
was a really well-made bot
and I'm just like, Jesus Christ.
I mean, I probably would
have fallen for it as well.
'Cause he's a good mate and like you-
- Yeah and that's the
thing, right, that's scary.
Especially when it's coming
from like a friend, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I dunno.
I feel in that situation,
like I think the best thing
to do maybe is to like
call them up, you know?
Just to like double-check, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Just to be like, sure.
- Yeah, I think that's what-
- 'Cause it's very hard to,
it's a little easier to fake a chat room
than it is to fake a phone call, you know?
- I think if, you know,
you did phone him before,
then it would have been sorted
out but sometimes, you know,
it was worded in a way where
he just, he just needed it now.
- And again, that's the scary thing.
It's just getting as better and better.
- That's probably where
having a Japanese bank account
would be an advantage
because then you'd be like,
"Sorry, sorry man, I've got to like,
book an appointment for tomorrow"
- "Can you wait a week,
that's the next open slot on my bank?"
- "You know, the next quarter is in like
three months, that's the best I can do"
- "I can't get a statement
until like three months from now,
I'm sorry, you're gonna
have to try someone else"
- "I'm sorry, man, I can't
do internet banking transfer"
- "Do you accept Western Union?"
I can give you that.
(laughter)
- Anyway, enough about
scams, I'm going to hijack
this podcast for a moment and turn it back
into an anime podcast.
- Oh, for fuck sakes.
- Because I just need to, okay?
- We don't watch anime.
- Just let me have this.
Let me have this Connor,
let me have this 'cause-
- I know exactly what
you're going to talk about.
(laughter)
- Of course you do.
- I don't.
- Of course you do Joey, so this weekend,
I watched the new Evangelion movie.
- Ah, fuck sakes.
(laughter)
- And I just, I need-
- How did you not
see this coming, Connor, he was literally
tweeting about it all week.
- I need to talk about this
because I need to move on with my life.
- This man's tweeted
about it, like he watched
like "13 Reasons Why" for the first time.
- I'm glad, though, you finally
watched it because again,
I watched it on the day it
came out in the cinemas,
which was like,
fucking six months ago or something.
It was a really, really long
time ago and I was like,
"I want to talk about it
so bad on the podcast,
but these two haven't seen it.
So I'm just going to like,
I'm just going to bottle this emotion up,
now I can finally pop the bottle!"
And talk about it.
- I watched it and I literally like,
cannot move on with my
life, like, I literally-
(Joey laughs)
- It's like witnessing the
death of a family member,
you know-
- Honestly...
- It's like actually mortifying.
I'm like, oh my God.
- So good or bad?
kind of death, like weird cousin
that you didn't really like or?
- I don't know how to like possibly
convey the feeling I felt
but what I will say is that,
I mean, like I shouldn't have
just, I shouldn't have ever
been a monk at all, right? that was like,
that was a fucking scam 'cause
if I wanted to feel Zen,
if I wanted to reach
Nirvana, I should have
just been an Eva fan, right?
Because I felt more Zen
after the End of Eva,
after this end of Eva,
than I ever did as a monk.
- Was it that good?
- It was-
- It's like, it's the type of movie
that you can't just clean-
- What is this?
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Let me explain.
- It's a simple
fucking question.
- Let me explain.
It's the type of movie that
you can't just clean up
with the word good.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Or bad.
- Because it's neither
of those, it's just like-
- That sounds like it's mediocre.
- No, it's definitely not.
- It's definitely
not mediocre,
- If it's anything,
it's not mediocre, it is the
polar opposite of mediocre.
- Yeah.
- I filled the MDB page.
The reviews were kinda-
- All over the place?
- Yeah seven, eight, it's
around about seven, eight.
- It's like, I think the
only way I can describe
that last movie is-
- Do you have
to have a very IQ to understand?
- Do you have to what?
- Honestly, yeah kinda.
- You kinda do, actually.
(laughter)
- I'm not even gonna like-
- That's why they called it--
- [All] 3.0+1.0
- Which is like the most
pretentious fucking title.
- It's very difficult to
figure out that that's four.
- If you can't perform
rudimentary mathematics
then you're just not even allowed.
- 'Cause you watched the original Eva
when it got released on Netflix, right?
- I did, I did.
- What was your opinions of-
- The TV series?
- At the time?
Yeah, he watched the TV series.
- Seven out of 10.
(Garnt laughs)
it was fine, you know,
I understand why everyone
is so hyped about it.
- Yeah, did you-
- I just,
I could see why you'd watch this
and you would remember this.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But I didn't think it was that amazing.
- Right.
- Yeah, I think like,
I think that's the common-
- It leaves an impression.
I think I'll say that much,
you know, and you can't,
you know, this isn't like
the irregular high school,
whatever the fuck that
one is where you're like,
I literally don't even know who you are
and I'm 20 episodes into this.
- It was four seasons of
that shit as well, yeah.
- See what I mean, I
didn't even know that.
- Yeah, there's like a spinoff
coming this season as well
and it's like, it's-
- Well yeah, you know,
it's one of those shows
that definitely was like,
I understand entirely why this is iconic
and everyone is in love with this.
- Yeah.
- I just personally
wasn't that into it.
- Did you leave satisfied?
- No, not at all.
- Okay, good, good.
'Cause I was like, 'cause
that was my experience.
- That was the worst part, is the ending.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Let me ask you then,
did you leave satisfied?
- With the original Eva?
- No, no, with 4.0.
- Oh, fuck yeah.
- Yeah, I-
- Like the TV series, though,
it was shit.
- No, no, no.
The TV series left everyone unsatisfied.
- I mean, like I remember the
first two times I watched Eva.
I fucking hated it.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- Because the first time I watched it,
I was 12, of course I wasn't gonna-
- Of course (laughs)
- Of course I was not going
to understand Eva when I was 12
and then I re watched it.
- Not enough IQ.
- Yeah, I re watched it to
review it as an Annie tuber
and then I was just
like this is even worse
than I remember it.
- Right, right.
- 'Cause now I now I'm actually invested
in the characters and the world
and the mysteries.
- You actually understand it,
sort of.
- It felt like a slap
in the face.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- Someone who spent all day watching it.
- Of course, what did I end up with?
Applause and congratulations, that's it.
Thanks.
(laughter)
- Is this it?
This is it?
- It's like the show
is mocking me being
like, "Congratulations,
you sat through all of this for nothing"
- Yeah.
- So they could what?
Milk another 50 years
out of this of movies?
- Hell yeah, dude.
- Is that literally it?
- Ano was five heading that shit.
He was planning ahead.
- He was fucking fiving
and then I remember going on
the internet fucking angry
and I'm just like,
"Surely they can't be the ending"
and then people were just like,
"Yo, have you heard of this movie called-
- End of Eva.
- End of Evangelion?
Which I'm-
- As in, the end of it?
- Which is--
(laughter)
I mean, it is an end of Eva.
Whether you are satisfied with-
- Is that the alternative ending one?
- Yes.
- It's alternative
but it's also cannon.
- Yeah, so-
- If that makes sense.
- So kind of the history
behind the first two,
the TV series ending
is that as you could probably
tell the studio just kind of
ran out of money and
ran out of like budget.
So they had to like piece
together something, right?
And so that was the ending that you saw
and so either like either
fans were so unsatisfied
that they sent Ano and
the company death threats,
or Ano himself was so
unsatisfied with the ending
that he decided to-
- He was like,
let's just "(mumbles) call it a day.
Fans'll love it"
- It's just art.
- Yeah, let's make another ending to Eva
and that's the end of Evangellion
and people were just like,
all right, I'm ready now.
This is the ending that
we never got for Eva.
- It's on the title of the movie.
- It's called End of Eva.
- And it's not
even the ending, right,
that's what I understand.
- It's a ending.
- It's definitely a ending
but it definitely doesn't
leave you satisfied.
- Okay, so what's the
watch order of Evangellion?
- One.
- No, no,
TV show, then movies?
- Ah, okay.
So 1.0
is basically the first,
I'd say 15 episodes of the TV series.
- Right, there's an abridged movie.
- It's basically just
like a Cliff Notes version
of the TV series and then
2.0 the first half of 2.0,
it approaches the original
ending of the TV series
but then goes on a different route.
- Oh, that's fucking cheeky that.
- Yeah, so he made-
- And this aired in theaters?
- This aired in theaters.
- This cheeky fuck.
(out of camera laughter)
Made one third of a movie
and called it a day?
- Pretty much, yeah.
- Oh my God.
Maybe I should just make shit things
and re-release them again in future
and add another-
- So basically,
the second half of 2.0 and you know,
mind you, I don't fully
remember everything
'cause it was a while
since I watched it but-
- I do, I do.
- But I'm pretty sure-
- You're talking to someone
who literally knows every frame
of the first movie 'cause
I fucking abridged it.
- Go on then, go on then.
- So like one point it was
basically just almost a
shot for shot recreation
of like the first four,
five episodes and then-
- Oh, with cleaner art, right?
- Yeah, cleaner art and minor,
minor, minor differences
and then 2.0, like it's
still like very, very similar
to like episodes, maybe
like six to 18 ish.
- For fuck sake.
- Yeah, I mean it goes,
it has other differences, it
introduces a new character,
which is the girl glasses and it has other
like-minded differences
but for the most part,
it's pretty much the same and then-
- I feel like introducing
a whole new character
is not the same.
- I mean-
- It's the same until you
introduce the character.
- For fuck sakes.
- Yeah.
It's the same until you introduce
her and then 3.0 and 4.0,
which I'm going to go,
which I'm going to call 4.0,
because three plus one is four.
- What asshole would call it that?
(laughter)
- It's dumb.
- Yeah, it is dumb.
- Why would they do that?
- It's an asshole called Anno Hideaki.
- For fuck sake.
- 3.0 and 4.0
are like completely different.
So it's like almost like a-
- That's completely original.
- Yeah.
- This feels
like the first time you
walked into Starbucks
and realized it was not
medium, small, large.
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- Why, why did you do this?
- It's like,
which one's Venti, which ones like large?
- What is a Venti?
- Wait.
Tall is medium?
- I still don't know
what a fucking Venti is,
I still don't understand.
- No, the part that fucked me up was like,
tall is not large.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Tall is medium.
- I fucking hate this.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like, what is that, like giant?
- No, no, no, tall is small.
- Tall is small.
- Grande is medium.
- No, no, no, no.
Wait, it is?
- Yeah, Grande is medium.
Venti is large.
- This is why I just
liked the chart, I can see the price.
That's how I decide.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Anyway, sorry, go on back to the 4.0.
- Back to the 4.0, yeah.
- Anyway, so 3.0 and 4.0
are completely original.
- Yeah.
- So I watched, okay, so I watched 3.0
on the day it came out in cinemas.
I was 16 when that came out.
- Okay.
- So it was literally 10 years ago
and I've only seen it once.
- Yeah.
- So imagine me going
to the cinemas day one,
airing 4.0 right now I'm like,
and I was like, "I got this"
(laughter)
I still remember.
- You don't got this.
- I don't, I was like, "I don't got this"
because literally the
first five minutes of 4.0,
it does a recap and I'm
like, oh, thank God.
That's great because there's
a 10 year gap, right?
- Yeah.
- So it goes through
like super fast, like super
artistic way of just being like,
here's what happened in 1.0,
here's what happened 2.0,
here's what happened 3.0, goes through 1.0
I'm like, okay, yeah, this
is just the TV series.
I've seen TV series many
times, got it in the bag.
2.0 it was like, okay,
yep, still the TV series
but introduced the new character.
All right, cool, yeah, 3.0 I'm just like,
"I don't remember any of that shit,
what the fuck is going on?"
And then 4.0 just begins
and I was like, "Cool"
So I'm literally going into this movie
with maybe about a 5% understanding of
what has happened so far.
- It's all good, man,
because I don't think that
would've helped you at all
(Joey laughs)
because the reason I didn't,
I chose not to see it
in cinemas, right, was because
obviously it wasn't subbed,
it was in Japanese.
- Of course.
- With a series like Eva,
I wanted to at least try
to understand what was going on.
'Cause I did remember
what happened in 3.0.
So I was like, I remember
most of the plot points,
so I'll be able to follow along easily.
So finally, I waited for it to
come out and I was just like,
I should have just seen this in theaters
because I have as much of an understanding
of what's going on in my own language
than I do in a fucking other language
that I'm barely understanding.
- For me 4.0 was like, "All right, cool.
That's a line, I understood
what they were saying.
I think I'm starting to get it"
and then literally the next line I'm like,
"I don't know what's going on"
(Garnt laughs)
and I'm like, "this is
a language I am fluent,
this is my first language
that they're speaking.
It sounds like a different language"
There's is so much terminology
and being thrown around,
which I'm sure there was
some kind of explanation
of probably in 3.0 but of course,
I have a 10 year gap with 3.0.
I don't remember that shit.
- The definitive way
to watch it is to watch
3.0 and immediately,
immediately start 4.0
- Probably.
- I don't think it even
matters because I doubt-
- You're not gonna remember it.
I doubt a lot of people are
going to be able to follow along
in the first watch through anywhere
because so much terminology
gets fucking thrown around
and gets like pulled out of his ass like,
some of the scenes I'm just like "Anno,
I don't know if you're a
genius or a madman" like-
- Oh yeah and then here's
the more fucked up thing
that I realized, if there's
anything I got out of 4.0,
it's the fact that there's
literally information in 4.0,
you will have no idea what the fuck it is
unless you read the manga.
- For fuck sake.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's like,
Anno literally took every iteration.
It was like, it took
bits from the TV series,
it took bits from End of
Eva, even a little bit
from Death and Rebirth and the manga
and just combined it all together.
So it's like-
- What's Death and Rebirth?
- That's the other movie.
(laughter)
- Yeah, it's just basically a recap movie.
- Oh, for fuck sakes.
- It's a recap movie
but there's like,
small minor details in "Death and Rebirth"
that are only specific
to "Death and Rebirth"
- But like, I've like,
for someone like you,
I wouldn't even recommend watching it.
- I'm exhausted hearing this.
- You don't have to
watch Death and Rebirth.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I mean-
- If you've watched two,
three and four?
- Yeah, I mean, if-
- And End of Eva.
- If you feel like it
because-
- Do I really?
Do I really have to watch End of Eva?
- I think no.
- End of Eva is-
- Like, if you're wanting
to get into End of Eva,
get into Evangellion as
a franchise, then yeah,
you need to watch End
of Eva but like, I mean,
it depends on what you're looking for.
'Cause if you're just looking
for like a normal TV series,
a normal story to get like
entertained, so much so where,
you know, you're like, you're looking
for like a normal plot arc,
you're looking for mysteries
to be solved, that's
just not going to happen,
as you've just experienced once.
I think what's so special
about Eva is that it's a series
that's just so powerful
that if you kind of relate
to what Anno was trying
to portray on screen,
like you said yourself, you
could tell why a lot of people
thought this, like a
lot of people saw this
as like a really powerful series
that affected them, right?
And it's just, 'cause it is
just that raw and powerful
because Eva to me, Eva,
like I didn't get Eva
the first few times I watched it.
Like I said, I was like, I hated that
and then like I reached later elite,
I reached a period in
life later where I started
to like fucking resonate more
with what was being portrayed
on screen, I wouldn't say I
understood the entire plot,
but I don't think that's the point of it.
I don't think the point of
Eva is to understand the plot.
Eva is to like, you know,
you can't just look at the shiny robots
fighting the big monsters
if you want but I think,
I think the true magic
of Eva was just Anno
pouring his heart out on
screen and capturing like
kind of like capturing
his psyche in a sense
and that's why it's like
that's why you can view it
and this, and you can just be like,
"I don't get it, this
is a complete mind fuck"
which it is.
It is an absolute mind fuck.
- Yeah, I truly think it is.
Especially with 4.0, I
truly think the only person
on the planet who can fully understand 4.0
and all of Eva is Anno because-
- Yeah, probably working on the movie,
they were like, what is-
- No, I guarantee it.
- I guarantee it.
- Because 4.0,
I feel, especially 4.0 is like a true,
not only is it like a
true love letter to Eva
but there's so much stuff
that Anno just crammed into it
that really has nothing to do with Eva.
It's literally like, he just
threw it in because he likes it
and I feel that's what Eva is.
It's like, it's literally a
series that Anno was like,
"I like robots, I like
monsters, I like Kaiju fights.
I love all of this shit
that I personally enjoy.
I'm going to cram this
shit into one series
and that's Eva"
- Yeah 'cause like, you
like you like BoJack, right?
- Yeah, I still haven't
watched the last season.
I'm too scared.
- Yeah.
'Cause I feel like BoJack is
probably the closest kinda
like closest big American show
that I can compare to Eva.
'Cause both deal with like-
- BoJack is the Eva
of cartoons.
- "Get in the robot, BoJack"
- It is kinda, it's such a
weird comparison but that is-
- BoJack is Shinji.
(laughter)
- I mean BoJack was like, I
guess BoJack was very clear
in what it was trying to portray.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- I guess I was slightly
confused many times during Eva.
I'm like, am I supposed
to feel sorry for Shinji?
- Well, that's an entire character study
in and of itself.
- Yeah.
Because both are the kind of same,
well they tried to tackle, they try
to tackle broken characters
trying to just find value
in themselves and just live
with themselves, right?
That's what both series tried to do.
BoJack has a much more
structured, you know,
much more structured story,
much more defined character arcs
and it's just easier to follow.
- And much less technical bullshit.
- I felt like, you know, in BoJack,
you got to like, see
why he was so fucked up
and I felt like in Evangelion,
we didn't really learn much about Shinji.
He was just whining.
- I mean,
I definitely feel like, I mean,
I think the finer details are there if,
for people who want to look into it deeper
but I feel especially the
movies do a really good job
in portraying Shinji as
this like broken kid.
- Yeah because I mean,
he's a 14 year old kid
who has like massive daddy issues
because his dad's an
absolute fucking asshole.
- Yeah.
- Never grew up with his mum,
is forced to pilot a fucking
giant robot the age of 14
and has to save the world.
- I don't know why he's sad
about this, this is amazing.
- I mean-
- 14 year old me would have killed
for the option to-
- I mean, I'm not going to,
obviously not going to
say any spoils for 4.0
but especially in 4.0, his dad is fucked.
- Yeah, he's like, I didn't think his dad
could get even more fucked.
- 4.0 it goes from like one
to a hundred, I'm like,
you can not be serious.
- Yeah but I think the reason Eva
is such an important
series to so many people,
including myself, is that it
just hits these emotional notes
that I've just never seen
in any other piece of media
and I just, I think that's
because Anno didn't give a shit
about telling a, you know, a
story that was easy to follow.
He just wanted to like,
put something out there.
He just wanted to put his
emotions into something.
- Yeah.
- And that's what I feel
from him and that's why it's
so like, to so many people,
this is such an important thing
because it's rare that you see something
that isn't like, that
isn't so well-defined
but that you can relate to on an,
in an emotional sense.
- It's almost not storytelling
like Anno's not really storytelling
as he is almost just emoting.
- I really can't describe Eva
without sounding like that
pretentious dick head, right?
'Cause I hear myself and I'm just like,
it's kind of just off.
- Well you know, I mean-
- What a wanker.
(laughter)
- It's one of those things
where I think I definitely
with TV shows and media, as
opposed to traditional art,
I very much prefer it when
they essentially tell me-
- Tell you, yeah.
- What trying to get across.
- Yeah, of course.
- And as much as you
could argue, okay, well, that's
for dumb people and whatnot
and it's like also like, well, you know,
I feel that if it is
art, I suppose it can be
but then also sometimes it isn't
marketed as such, you know,
like when you look at a painting,
there's no doubt in
your mind that it's art
and you can interpret it however you want
and you get whatever you want out of it
but I think with TV shows, because it's
such a different medium it's, you know,
what is art supposed to
be when it's TV and film?
- But I would argue that some
of the best shows are the ones
that can present an artistic
idea in an artistic way
but make it simple enough
for anyone to enjoy, right?
Like I feel that's like
really good storytelling.
- Well, that's where I think
BoJack Horseman is amazing.
- Yeah, yeah, I agree.
- BoJack Horseman-
- I felt like it delivered a topic
that I think a lot of people and a lot
of older people don't really
think about or care about.
- Don't talk about.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I think like I'm not
bringing down BoJack.
'Cause I also think it's
an amazing fucking show.
I just think like Evangellion was,
is so unique because you know,
if there's one thing that
doesn't make fucking sense
or you can't logically always
follow its emotions, right?
Sometimes you just feel
something and you just like,
"Why the fuck, why do I feel this?
Like, I just logically
don't know why I feel this
and I shouldn't feel this"
- Yeah.
- And like, that's what
Eva portrays so well.
It's not meant to be
logical in a lot of senses
but sometimes you just see
something, I'm just like,
"I don't know why I kind of relate to this
but I just do.
I don't know why I resonate with this
but I just do"
and that's been my experience with Eva
and I guess the biggest thing
that I never got from Eva
was the satisfying
conclusion of like closure.
Like this is it.
- An actual ending.
- Like this is it, I am
satisfied because you know,
I kind of, you know, as an Eva fan
you find your own fucking closure.
You've watched End of Eva and you're like,
"What the fuck did I just watch?
I need someone--"
sometimes you need someone
to help you process what you just watched.
and like,
you know, that sometimes you
spend hours reading up analysis
and reading up this and reading up that
and you're just like-
- End of Eva
is one of those movies where like,
you watch it and you
go, "That was awesome"
but then the moment your
brain actually kicks in
and goes, "But do you
know what it was about?"
That's the one, that's
the moment where you have
like the existential dread, like, "Wait,
maybe it wasn't good, what was it about?"
- Why do you think I didn't enjoy
or connect with Evangellion, do you reckon
there was a reason why?
- I feel maybe
it's because you were kind of over-hyped
from like the outside, I think maybe-
- That's possible.
- What were your expectations
coming in?
- Something deep.
- Maybe that's what it is, right?
- Yeah, something impactful.
- Because Eva is like,
Eva is simultaneously the deepest thing
but also at the same time,
something that doesn't
make any fucking sense.
- I mean,
it's not something you watch
to per se enjoy because I remember like,
the only times I've actually, like,
I actually kind of understood
Eva really depended
on what mindset I was in, I couldn't just-
- Yeah, I thought, I
was under the impression
that it was going to be some
form of interesting take
on like being a teenager and struggling
with mental health issues.
- It was.
I mean, to a certain point.
- I mean, it is.
It's just not told in a way
that is just traditional.
You know, it's told a very raw way,
where it's just, they don't care about you
following the story,
they just wanted to like
put these raw thoughts and
raw emotions, put it on screen
and then just like, just put
it out there and that's what,
like, that's what I got from
Eva, which is why like the,
the time that I connected with
Eva the most just happened
to be the points when I was
in the worst point in my life.
It's, you know, it's just something
where it's not something I think people
should watch to enjoy, I
think people should watch it
to experience it and maybe
you didn't enjoy this time.
I didn't enjoy the first time I watched it
but maybe there would be a
point when you're just like,
where some of the words or
something from it rang out to you
and just like, maybe this is the time-
- Garnt, are you saying that Eva
is an acquired taste?
(laughter)
- No Joey, stop putting words in my mouth.
And what I will say about End of Eva 4.0,
without spoiling what happens.
'Cause I'm not, I'm not going to spoil it.
That explains the only
thing I will kind of say
is that it is a conclusive full stop
and I remember because growing
up, I can't like, I don't,
I don't know how to convey to
you what it's like growing up
with a franchise and
being like, this has got,
this franchise is going
to be around forever.
There is never going to be
an end for this franchise
and you kind of make
peace with that, right?
- Yeah
- 'Cause I remember
when the movie got
released, I think I remember
we were meeting up to be like, "Oh,
I can't wait for 5.0, in my
20 years, can't wait for,
I know to like dig up the grave of Eva"
And I remember like,
I talked to plenty of Japanese
people who were just like,
no, "This is the end" I
was like, "Sure, sure"
Yeah, Joey goes sees it, Nabo goes sees it
and they're like, "This is the end"
I'm like, "Sure, all right, bet"
- It's literally, you won't
believe it until you see it.
- Yeah, yeah, it is, it is and then-
- I'll watch the movies.
- I mean, you can,
I like, I'm not like, I have like.
- I've decided, I'm going to watch them.
- You're going to watch them?
- You have decided?
- I'll watch the movie.
- Where?
I think all four movies
are on Prime Video.
- Yeah, Netflix and all of End of Eva,
all of Evangelion the
original series is on Netflix
and all of the movies are on Prime Video.
of all four of the movies.
- [Connor] Yeah.
Just because like, why
not, 'cause like, again,
I've only seen 3.0 and 4.0 once
and I'm like-
- What, like on Stream?
- Yeah, on Stream.
- Oh, what, you press play?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah 'cause like
Twitch has a thing for that.
- I might do that.
- Yeah.
- There's a thing for that now?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, there's
a thing for that now.
- Wait, what?
- Like a watch party function.
- What's that like?
- So basically,
it's like the Twitch thing, I think this
is a relatively new thing but basically,
when you do a watch party together now,
when you go to that person's Twitch page,
the person streaming is
actually in the corner now
and you get prompted to
log into your Prime Video
or Netflix.
- Oh shit.
- And it like, and it syncs up.
- What?
- Yeah.
- Dude!
- And it's like,
a brand new thing now,
yeah, my Twitch partner-
- You can online stream now?
- Yeah.
- No fucking joke.
- That's a game changer.
- Holy-
- I can work
and watch Netflix?
- Yeah.
So my Twitch partner was like, oh,
since all the Eva movies
are on Prime Video
and Twitch has this new thing now,
you can easily do a watch party.
- I'm like, oh fuck
yeah, dude, let's do it.
- Jeff Bezos owns that
too, he owns all of these.
Oh my God.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But of course, on Amazon Prime.
- So now you can-
- Now, now-
- Now you can cry on Stream.
- Yeah.
- Or get very confused.
- Honestly, okay, so I got to ask you,
what was your reaction when-
- All right, I'm out.
- All right, when, okay, okay-
- Obviously, no spoilers
in this episode, obviously.
- No, no, no, I just
want to know what your,
I just want to know
what your reaction was-
- Yes, your reaction.
- When the credits
started rolling.
started rolling?
- Yeah.
I'm sorry Connor, I just need-
- No, no, no.
- I just need to gush.
I just need to gush.
- I've literally never,
I think that might be
the first time in my life
where the term dumb founded
is like actually eligible
because like, I think if you had,
if I had seen myself
in the cinemas, right?
I probably would have made a face like...
For the entire credits just
because because my brain,
I don't think could process
what the fuck I just watched
and like, because I went
to go see it with Ken
who was on the show, right and
he was obviously, you know,
during the credit
sequence, he was just like,
"Oh, I know that anime, I've had that"
Meanwhile like what Ken was
saying was just going in one ear
and out the other.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause I was like, "Ken,
don't give me more information.
I'm still trying to process
everything I literally
just watched" and yeah, I dunno.
Like it was, I think the
best way to describe 4.0
for me was it was very bittersweet.
- Yeah.
- Because it's like you,
it's not until really those credits end
and you walk out of the
cinemas that you realize, oh,
this is really it.
- Yeah.
- Like there isn't gonna be
another movie anymore, I mean,
maybe there will be, maybe
there'll be a spin off
or something, I don't know.
- This story has ended, right?
- Yeah, this movie franchise has ended.
Like something I fucking
grew up with my whole life.
- Yeah.
- And like, I dunno,
I was like, "Is this how I'm going to feel
when like One Piece ends?" or like-
- That's how I felt when
Arthur got canceled.
(laughter)
- I don't, I don't even want to-
- I can't believe they canceled Arthur.
- Yeah.
- Arthur got canceled?
- Arthur got canceled.
- When?
- Like right after the episode
where I said "Arthur
will never be canceled"
- Are you serious?
(laughter)
- Yes (laughs)
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- It literally got canceled.
- Oh my God.
- I just assumed Arthur
was going to be there
when I had like grandchildren children.
- Yeah, right, yeah.
- Fuck man.
- Yeah.
So like, I dunno, like I feel this is how,
because I've obviously never experienced
like a show I grew up with,
like a big, big franchise
like that to just end
in my lifetime, right?
Like I feel this is how it's going to be
when like One Piece, or like Jojo or like-
- I don't even want to
imagine when One Piece
and Jojo ends.
- Yeah, right?
- Holy fuck.
- Like I feel that emotion
that I felt at the end of
4.0 is how I'm going to feel
and it's not a great feeling.
- It was like,
'cause it's rare enough
that I watch something
and I feel something
I've never felt before,
which is exactly what I felt because this
is something I grew up with,
something I always thought
would be there, right
and then it's just like,
it's just over.
- And really does feel
like a family pet has just died.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know?
It's like, it's something
that, it really is,
it's like, it's honestly,
it's that same emotion.
- Honestly, I started fucking bawling man
'cause like, here's the thing,
I wasn't even hyped for 4.0.
Right 'cause like nine years
had passed since the fast,
since the last week and I'm just like,
whatever, it's out, I'll
watch it out of obligation.
I love Eva but I don't,
I could go my entire life
without watching another Evangelion movie
and I would have been
completely satisfied.
So I watched it literally out
of obligation and then like,
I think the last half hour
hit and I'm just like,
"Oh my God, what is this
I'm feeling right now?
Is this a feeling of
closure, am I closing a page
in my life right now?" I'm just like,
"What is this feeling?"
- Yeah.
- And then the end credits,
felt like the end credits
started rolling and I just,
process is the right word
because there are so many
emotions coming up at once
that I just, I didn't know
how to process them all
and you just felt empty
and you just felt like,
I felt like a fucking void
in my life and I'm just like,
there's nothing that's going
to fill this hole up anymore.
That's why I need to talk about it.
That's why I'm so desperate to, because-
- Because I remember as well,
like when the first posters
for 4.0 released in
Japan, the tagline for it
was (speaking Japanese) which
means goodbye Evangelion
and I was like, okay, that's
kind of a cool, very, you know-
like very like artistic,
like kind of tagline.
I didn't think anything of it, right?
But then when they said
that line in the movie
at a particular scene, I was like,
"No,
don't do this to me man, don't leave me!"
- "I'm sorry, I should
have treated you better"
- "I should have treated you better.
I should have treated
you more, more, right.
Don't leave me, not now"
and like that was the moment
where I was like, oh, okay like this,
that point I think really solidified to me
how important this series was to me.
- I'd forgotten it was until that moment
and like, I've been doing ever since,
I've ever since that movie I could,
I've not been able to watch anything else.
I've not been able to play any games.
I just feel like the emptiness.
- You literally can't
consume any other media
for at least a week.
- Yeah.
'Cause like I tried to and I'm just like,
"This ain't Eva, what's the point?"
- That's why I'm really
scared to rewatch it.
- Yeah.
- I tried playing League.
Lost, I'm just like, "Don't care"
- Is that how it should all be ending?
- I was just like, nothing's
going to fill this void.
- It's like that moment after you cum.
You just don't feel anything,
you just sit there like,
no emotion.
- I think I've just
reached Zen, like I feel like
I've reached enlightenment.
Like fuck being a monk, man, like is this
what it feels like, you
just like an open book
and you just like, I finally-
- Who would have thought
you could become a monk
with a 6.99 membership.
- I'm finally at peace with
my life and now I just want
to get the hell this on, I
just want to move on now.
- So for anyone watching
this who's never seen Eva,
we're not coming onto here
saying that we recommend you
to watch Eva, it's hard to recommend-
- It's hard to recommend
now because you're not
going to have the same experience
that we had where you just like,
where you grew up with this,
so, and you know, like I said,
if you're someone who's going
in a tough time in your life,
then I honestly recommend
you experience it
because maybe it will teach
you something about yourself.
- I was gonna say, I was like,
you know, if you haven't had any struggles
with mental health, is it hard
to appreciate stuff like that?
- I think so.
- Because like after I watched Eva,
I've like, I've just been binge-watching
so many like Eva analysis videos but like-
- I'm the same.
- Which is like,
I guess like my way of coping.
- I think Ken and I had
about a six hour conversation
and Hezekiah about just
the movie we just watched,
the entire time.
- Yeah and I think the video
that I like related to the
most in terms of what I felt
when I watched the first time was-
- Was Eva abridged.
- No no, no, no.
Scamboni Reviews
did a video called "You
Don't Understand Eva"
right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- In like sarcastic text, you know,
where he basically broke
down why Eva is like,
basically a really badly told plot.
Like he basically broke it down
in a way where I
completely agreed with him.
I would've completely agreed with them.
'Cause that was basically
what I was trying to say
when I had watched first time
because I just didn't resonate
or relate to anything
that was trying to say.
- No, me neither, you know,
I didn't really feel sorry
for Shinji at all, I felt
like I was supposed to.
- That's the thing,
the emotions were there
but the execution was not there.
- I mean, like, I don't think
like you were even supposed
to feel sorry for him,
right because yeah, exactly.
like either you do feel sorry for him
or you don't, like a
lot of people would do
because a lot of people relate
to that kind of mental space.
Right that they can resonate with that
but like the series doesn't
explicitly tell you,
you should feel sorry for this
person, this person is this,
it's just, that's kind of like,
that's kind of like the
thing that maybe like not,
not everyone will enjoy Eva,
not everyone should enjoy it.
I mean, I wouldn't recommend it to someone
in a very healthy mental
state because one,
you probably wouldn't get it and two,
I wouldn't wish for you to
be in a bad mental state
to begin with to get it, right, yeah.
- I mean, you know,
BoJack, I thought was great
'cause I wasn't depressed watching it
but I certainly was after.
- Well, yeah,
I mean like things like
BoJack and like, you know,
we related Eva to BoJack
but I think like something
like Oyasumi PunPun. is probably closer
in terms of like actually, you know,
presenting a very sad story
in a way that can get anyone
of any mental state invested
in the story of BoJack, right?
Like, you know, BoJack
in that case was told
in a very like straightforward,
like here's the thing that's fucked up.
You know, this is why
you should feel sorry
and for most people, they felt sorry.
- [Connor] It was very easily presented.
- It was, yeah, easily presented but like,
I feel Eva in that
sense is almost so vague
with what they want the viewer to feel.
- Yeah.
- To the point
where it's like, here are the emotions
that you should be feeling but
we're not going to tell you
to feel those emotions specifically.
That's up to you to decide.
- Yeah.
- Kind of thing.
- Like, I don't trust anyone
who says they understand Eva,
like you can spend all like-
- It just sounds like you
can have an interpretation
of Eva.
- You can
have an interpretation of Eva.
- Oh, there's many,
many interpretations.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But to claim to understand
Eva I feel like is just,
I don't, I honestly
don't think it's possible
and I'm sure there are some
Eva fans that are out there
that are just like, I
can't believe he said that.
- Um, actually.
(laughter)
- But like I've spent
so many fucking hours
watching different people analyze it,
different people's
interpretation but like,
there are so many different
interpretations of the series
to begin with that I just
think that's the thing, right?
There's a reason why we
are still discussing it
to this day 26 years later.
- Yeah.
- And I think it'll always be discussed.
- I remember, it was
a couple of years ago,
I think like when we
were still in the rush
of all these people, you know,
just analyzing every
single piece of imagery
from the TV series, right and
one that got discussed a lot
was when the angels explode,
they create an explosion
that looks like a cross.
- Yeah.
- And there was, I watched
so many analysis videos
being like, this is why
Anno chose the cross
and why it's super symbolic
and blah, blah, blah
and then a couple of years later,
they came out with an interview with Anno
and they were asking,
"So is there any reason
why when the angels explodes,
it turns into a cross?"
And he literally just said,
"I just think it looks cool"
(laughter)
It doesn't mean anything
and all the anime YouTubers
were like, "We spent all
this time analyzing something
that you just put in
because it looks cool?"
And I feel like that alone
to me really showed the fact
that Anno doesn't think this shit is deep.
He just put it in because it's cool.
- Also, if you're saying that
you didn't have time or money
to make a proper ending-
- Yeah.
- What's the odds that he had the time
to be able to be like, no,
no, no change the explosion
to a cross.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like this is why you should do this
because it's symbolic to the story.
No, because it's just a love letter
to all the shit Ano likes, he's like,
I think the cross looks
cool, let's add that shit in.
- Yeah, I mean, at the same time,
I would say that maybe he
didn't make a conscious choice.
He put stuff in just
because it felt right.
It looked right and it
created a certain tone,
a certain mood, whatever.
- Especially in 4.0.
- And you can analyze that
but to say that everything
had a purpose and everything
was put there for a reason,
I think, no, no, not everything in Eva,
I don't think Anno knew everything
that he knew what he wanted to say in Eva.
- I think especially in 4.0 as well,
there was so much shit in there, I'm like,
that doesn't make any
sense, why is that there?
Oh, fuck it, you know what is on there?
Just let him do what he wants to do.
Yeah.
- Well, I guess
like moving on from
like Eva as a franchise,
we can like tag you back in now, Connor.
We can tag you back in.
(Joey laughs)
Like, has it been any other
like points or like series or franchise
where you've kind of like grown up with
that franchise and you've had like,
you've seen the franchise come
back years and years later
and you view it differently as an adult,
as opposed to when you saw it as a kid?
- Aw, geeze.
- 'Cause I remember
the first time it happened to me was,
I remember when Toy Story 3 got released.
- I was literally thinking Toy Story 3
when you said that.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, I
feel that's the only thing
that's like stuck around, right?
- I think there's been two,
there's been Toy Story three
and American Pie Reunion.
- Right.
(laughter)
- What, what?
- I can't relate
to the latter, unfortunately.
- I think that American Pie
was like, 'cause like when American,
when American Pie one
and two got released,
it was fucking massive during,
not even like my generations,
but I think like I
already saw American Pie
because it was like my
older cousins' generation
and they would like put it
on TV and I'm just like,
"There's fucking boobs,
what the fuck is going on here?"
- [Joey] "Am I even allowed to be here?"
- "Am I allowed to be here?"
- Imagine that came out today.
- Yeah, no, oh my God but
I remember watching like,
'cause that's how I experienced
American Pie one and two
and it was fucking massive and then
seeing American Pie Reunion
and just seeing everyone
as just like responsible adults
and just like being adults.
- That's what that's about?
- Yeah, having like children, like,
'cause they have a high school reunion
and you see these
characters and they're, one,
they're like a lot older
and people have jobs
and they have children and I'm just like,
what the fuck is this, what's
happened to my childhood?
- It's like a real high school reunion.
- Everyone's still in a uni, right?
Everyone's still getting
pissed and partying, right?
- I'm pretty sure I saw his dad,
you know his dad, in American Pie?
- Yeah.
- The one who's
in every movie?
- Yeah.
- Pretty sure I just saw him in Canada
when I was on like the ski lift.
- Really?
- I'm pretty sure I sat
next to him, I'm near certain I did.
(Joey laughs)
He spoke to me as well ad
he had the exact same voice,
but I couldn't exactly see his face.
He's wearing ski stuff.
- Right, right, right.
- But he looked like it and I was like,
"I think this is him"
- You should have
just been like, are you
the dad from American Pie?
- I didn't ask him, I wasn't
sure and imagine if he wasn't,
he'd be like, what the fuck is that?
- Then you could have spun it being like,
you sound just like him.
- I'm near certain it's him
but I was like 14, so I didn't want to-
- Oh, right, right.
- But I was like, I swear,
I swear it's fucking you.
- How do you remember
that shit?
- 'Cause he literally
just reminded me, I remember
getting off the ski lift
thinking like, was that, was
that the guy from American Pie?
- Did you see like, these
fucking bushy ass eyebrows?
- Yes!
(laughter)
- Of course, that's the
one thing I remember.
- Bushy ass eyebrows.
- He has like,
the exact same skin tone,
the voice was like, spot on.
I was like, what the fuck, is this him?
Is this him?
- No but like, yeah.
Well, I mean, have you
seen all the Toy Stories?
- I haven't seen Toy Story four.
- Good.
- I was like Toy Story three-
- Don't.
- Toy Story three
was my Ava 4.0, you know, where-
- Wait, what?
(laughter)
- No, no, no, where I
watched it and I'm just like,
that was a nice sendoff to Toy Story.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And then,
they made a fourth one and
I'm just like, fuck this shit.
- Yeah, don't bother with the fourth one.
- Did you like three, I
didn't really like three.
- I didn't like it so much, I liked,
it felt special to me
because it felt like,
you know, I was saying goodbye.
- "The end of an era"
- The end of Story Story.
- The end of Toy Story,
3.0, Death and Rebirth.
(laughter)
No but just like seeing
Andy grow up and seeing-
- Yeah, it's all right, I guess.
- I mean-
- We need like a Toy Story,
like 1.0, yeah.
- What is the plot
of Toy Story 4? why is there-
- They're at the circus, I don't even,
I haven't even watched.
- So I saw Toy Story 4
in cinemas because it was available.
I went to go see with Aki
just 'cause we were like,
"We want to go to the cinemas,
what's playing right now?
Oh, Toy Story 4 is there, all right,
let's go watch it?"
'cause at that point, I hadn't
heard anything about it.
So I went to go see it,
yeah, it fucking sucks.
It really does suck, I
mean, the movie is decent
but literally the last
15 minutes of that movie,
not only ruin the movie
but just completely
ruin the entirety of
the Toy Story franchise.
- Yeah, I heard it
broke a lot of the rules
and also it kind of like
ruined Woody's character.
- Yeah, it completely
destroyed every character
and it just ends off with like this,
well, Woody's on the road now.
- But I'm also not that invested
in the cast of Toy Story.
So if you know, if Buzz
commits war crimes,
I'm not really going to care that much.
I'm just going to be like, "All right.
Well, I mean, he shouldn't
have bombed that place
but okay"
- But at least
Toy Story 3, right, obviously
not going to spoilers
but at least Toy Story 3--
- I think you could
spoil Toy Story 3.
- Really?
- I think it's okay to spoil.
- I don't know.
There might be people that
are like, I can't believe-
- This is not, this is not 4.0.
You can spoil Toy Story.
- I can't believe they ruined
the ending of Toy Story 3 for me.
- You can spoil Toy Story 3.
- All right, well, okay, well,
with Toy Story 3, like,
you know that scene
where Woody's like, "So long, partner?"
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like that was
like really fucking nice.
- That was pretty good.
- Like that made me tear up a little bit.
Not going to lie.
- I just didn't like
the fuzz bear, the care bear
villain, I just didn't like-
- Well, I mean, at least
it didn't last, right?
- Yeah, I guess so.
- It didn't last.
- I think the scene that stuck out to me
with Toy Story 3, if we're getting
into spoiler territory-
- The incinerator scene?
- Yeah, the incinerator scene.
- Yeah, of course.
- You talk shit.
- What?
- I hated that scene.
- It just dragged on, you
knew what was going to happen.
He was like, come on, then, all right.
(laughter)
- Wait, what?
- Are you a fucking
movie critic, right?
- What, do you think
they should have died?
- I would have,
it would've been a nice twist.
(Garnt laughs)
- Critical!
(laughter)
- Famous Pixar movie.
- What if they
just then clear cut to like the factory
where they make Buzz and
Andy, it's just like.
- It just cuts like a pile of ashes.
- Should have pulled
like a Rick and Morty.
Like, actually, that was
the alternative universe of,
you know-
- That would have
truly ruined Toy Story.
- We say like 10,000 Buzzes
in like Toy Story 2, why couldn't we have
like Spanish Buzz takeover, you know?
(off camera laughter)
Like what's, why, why?
- El Buzz.
- Why?
- I'll tell you
who would've killed
off the Toy Story cast?
- Who?
- Hiri Akiano.
- Yeah, yeah, he would've killed them off
and been like, they're all
toys, they all share one mind.
- They go into the incinerator
and then they explode in a giant cross.
(laughter)
The end.
- The end.
- Fuck your childhood, kids.
- They're toys,
if they went anywhere near an incinerator,
they would've melted and been deformed.
- Well, yeah, of course.
- Also, what year is this
where we have incinerators
attached to like kindergartens
or whatever?
- That is true.
- Who installed an incinerator
in the kindergarten?
How irresponsible is
this, why was that there?
- "Don't go near that room, children"
- Wait, is this-
- Was it in the kindergarten?
- It was nearby, right?
- I completely-
- Or something?
- I'm pretty sure
it was nearby or something.
- I don't know.
Why, I just, my gosh.
- Didn't they go
to a garbage dump?
- I don't fucking know.
- Yeah, that's right.
(cross talk)
- I just thought it was
attached to like the school.
The kindergarten.
- That would've
been the real plot twist.
- It had been like,
it was actually a disposal site all along.
It was not a kindergarten, I don't know.
- Connor just fucking Memento'd himself.
Where like you just like, I'll tell you,
you King Crimsoned yourself
where like a time period
just fucking disappeared.
- I think so.
- And you're like, "I
guess they just ended up
in a fucking incinerator"
- I was so bored
at that point in the movie because one
and two I liked a lot, I liked that a lot.
I love the scene where he's like,
"Oh, I got to drive to work"
and then he crosses the street
in his car.
- Yeah.
That scene was a banger.
- That's a classic.
- That's a classic scene.
- I love that.
- Just naming off memes now, man.
- Toy Story one and two are actually
like really fucking funny.
- Yeah.
- Okay, can I just say, Toy Story 2,
that scene at the airport is
still one of my favorites.
- [Connor] It's amazing.
- That fight scene,
can I call it a fight scene?
- Yeah, yeah.
That's a fight scene.
- Yeah, that squabble scene.
- I felt, you know, a lot of the modern,
I can watch a lot of the older films
that I haven't even
watched before, kids ones
and I thought that they were
really good because they just,
you know, as an adult, you can watch them,
no problem.
But I find that when I watched a lot
of the new kids films, I can't
watch them because I just-
- Oh, you're talking
about recent Pixar films
and stuff like that, right?
- Yeah.
I feel like they've been like,
I mean, this is a common
thing where everyone's like,
"Oh, they've been dumbed down"
but I did feel that like,
when I watch a lot of the
older movies, like Disney,
like eighties to two thousands,
like I can watch any of them.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like, this is good but a kid
could watch them as well.
- I mean like,
I did have like a period
where I actually sat down
and like watched all of like
the recent Disney movies
and the recent Pixar movies
'cause I wanted to make sure
and I was like, is it
actually getting dumbed down?
Or is that just like my
like own opinion about it?
- Like, have you watched Pinocchio?
That movie's fucked.
- Yeah.
That movie is-
- I do not remember Pinocchio.
Have you watched Pinocchio?
- I might have.
- Dude, they fucking
smoke cigars and they turn into donkeys.
- They smoke cigars,
gamble and drink alcohol
and I'm like, what the hell?
- Yeah
and these kids are like eight years old.
- I don't remember Woody
like cracking open a bong.
(Garnt laughs)
Do you know what I mean, like-
- Buzz!
(laughter)
- "Buzz, yeah, are you gonna hit the bong?
Andy's in college bro,
let's hit the bong!"
- It's huge!
- The bong
just starts talking.
(laughter)
It's just Seth Rogan, like,
I don't remember this.
- Pretty sure that's just
fucking Sausage Party, man.
- I'm pretty sure this is actually like a-
- The Playboy magazine comes to life.
- This is like a cartoon, Robot Chicken.
- Yeah, it's like a New Ground spinoff.
- I think this is, pretty
sure this is a thing.
I don't know.
- I don't know.
- Yeah, wait, there was a Robot Chicken
where like they go to, am
I dreaming this weather?
Like they do Toy Story
parody and like dildos talk
or something.
- I don't know.
That's a million dollar idea.
- Maybe I've made this up.
If not, that's all yours, I mean,
that's low hanging fruit but-
- I feel like that
sounds like a fever dream
but most Robot Chicken skits
are fever dreams.
- Adult Toy Story.
- I feel like, with
movies, I can't remember
what I've made up and
what is actually happening
and what has happened.
- You shouldn't
share too much, man, you're giving away
a million dollar ideas left and right.
- The thing is, I'll have this idea,
oh, it's already been
done, it was never done.
It was never done.
- Until it wasn't.
- I have an absolutely horrid memory.
Just absolutely abysmal when
it comes to remembering films
and media, I just can't,
I remember what I felt-
- You remember JoJo and
that's pretty much it.
- I remember what I felt about the media.
I can't remember much about it.
Just like one or two
scenes here and there.
That's all I remember.
- I think
that's pretty common, though.
- Is that common?
- Well, I think especially if you-
- I can't remember character names either.
- I'm also shit at
remembering character names.
- Yeah but I feel that's
especially the case
for people who have consumed
like a shitload of media.
Right, like after a while,
like your brain's gonna overcap
with that kind of shit.
- Is this
just the modern day
problem of too much media?
- Too much consumption.
- Too much media.
I can't remember fucking anything.
Now I'm watching YouTube
shorts and I feel like my brain
has like one second memory.
(laughter)
- I feel like the shorts are not helping.
- Yeah, TikTok and the shorts, definitely
haven't helped in hacking
your brain to be like, okay,
on to the next thing,
consume, consume, consume.
- But then I talked to my dad and he like,
can't remember the word
for anything and I'm like,
shit is that what I'm going to be like?
I'm like-
- I think
that's a different problem.
(laughter)
- He just refuses to learn, like if you,
if he's learned a word a certain way,
he just will never correct it.
- What do you mean?
- Like he-
- Like pronouncing or like-
- Yeah, pronunciation.
He will never change the
pronunciation once he's decided
what the pronunciation is in his head.
- I don't think that's a memory issue.
I think that's just being stubborn.
(laughter)
- But that, I think that
is like an older thing.
'Cause I think I've met a
few older people who do that.
Where you like, you
correct the pronunciation.
They're like, "No"
- My dad is like that as well.
My dad's like, he tells
a fact and then I go,
"Actually it's not" and then he's like,
"Nah, that's not a credible source"
- Honestly, I'm kind of like that.
- Yeah, I know.
- Are you going to tell me
that gif is not pronounced gif?
- It is gif, I don't give
a shit if he says jif.
- It's gif.
- That's the point, right?
- I don't give a shit if
that guy says it's jif.
It's not.
- I don't give a shit.
It's gif.
- It's gif.
- And like fucking the
world could end and like-
- You don't have a say,
even though you made it,
you don't have a say.
- The G stands for graphic.
You don't say jraphic.
- No, exactly.
- It's a g sound, it's gif.
- Like there could be like,
there could be a gun to my head
to be like, you can live
if you just say jif.
I'll be like, no, shoot me now.
- Gif.
- Shoot me.
- Bang.
(laughter)
- I'll take the gun off him, it's gif.
I don't know, even if you made the thing.
I think you can have, you know,
if you've made it clear from the start,
that it was that,
and that's what it was but it
became massive public domain
and was widely used before it became
into the public discourse
that it was called jif.
- Right, right, right.
- So at that point,
no, he might've been saying it
for a while but he
didn't do a very good job
of making everyone know it was jif.
He should, everything at the
bottom showed a watermark
saying it is pronounced
jif to make it clear
but I feel like as a
creator, you didn't really
have much say over how.
- Especially when it becomes
that widespread, it's already
like rooted into society.
- There are so many things that like,
once they're adopted by
the public, you know,
they become their own
kind of beast, right?
It becomes its own thing.
- Yeah.
- And you don't really get a say over it.
- Well that's like, you know,
if Anno came out tomorrow
and said it's actually
pronounced Evanjellion.
We'd all be like, "No, it's not"
It's Evangellion.
- Okay, yeah.
- It's like JK Rowling telling us
like weird Harry Potter
facts, like they just,
they shit themselves then teleported away.
(Joey laughs)
No, I don't believe you.
Even though you made this
and this is your world,
no, you don't have a say in this.
- It's pronounced Harry Pooter, actually?
- You don't have a say over it.
What was the other weird
one that they brought out?
Like something weird
about Hagrid or something.
- It was, Dumbledore's gay or something.
- Dumbledore's gay.
- No, no, no.
That was already-
- No but that's canon.
- Yeah, that was already
canonical, there's another one
with like Hagrid where
it was like something
really fucking weird about Hagrid.
- I can't remember.
- He was like onto anal
or something.
- And I was like, no, no.
It was like-
- Hagrid
had a fucking threesome
with Snape and Dumbledore.
- McGonagal.
- And it's canon.
It's just like, what are
you doing JK Rowling?
Why, why are you doing this?
- It happens
in between the first two books.
I just didn't write it.
- It's interesting though,
isn't it, how like, if you
do try and retcon things
or what it feels like retconning,
the audience would be like, "No"
- Yeah, I mean, Anno has done
that several fucking times
because he's come out several
times saying like, no,
it's not like that, like for example,
the crosses.
- "The cross
doesn't mean anything"
or "I just put this in
because I thought it was cool" and then-
- Yeah, I guess, so, I guess it comes off-
- And people are like, "No, no, no"
- But then that's
interesting, right 'cause then
that begs the argument of,
it's not whether as much as,
it's not really anything to
do with the media itself.
It's more so to do with
what the public likes you
and like is life.
- That is true.
It's whether or not the public actually
takes you seriously
- So even if she released a new book,
I'm sure people will be like,
"Nah, it's not canonical.
I just don't like it, I
just don't like it" do I?
- Sometimes you, sometimes you
just got to decide, you know?
- And also I think, I
think she has pushed it
with what she can get the
audience to agree with.
- Yeah.
- I think once you've
brought in these characters
and you've brought in this world,
there's a certain amount of, ah, no,
I don't not really agree with that.
- Well, I mean, she certainly
hasn't helped her public image
with that kind of stuff, right?
Meanwhile, if like fucking Nasu came out
with another Fate thing, it was like,
ah, yes, this is actually not canonical,
all the Nasu fans will be
like, yes, thank you, Nasu.
Thank you for another piece.
- Was Anno ever ridiculous
with the stuff that he suggested?
- Have you seen Eva?
(laughter)
- Yeah but like it's all always in line.
You know, hearing JK-
- Eva is the definition
of ridiculous.
- Yeah
but that's why it's in line, Harry Potter
had rules to some extent.
- Yeah.
- And to hear her go "Yeah, the reason
why Hagrid doesn't have kids is 'cause
he exclusively fists people"
that's not something that,
(laughter)
that doesn't line up-
- He's incapable
of reproducing.
- You know,
that doesn't line up
with what I understood
about Harry Potter.
- Right, right.
(laughter)
- To say that is like, "Okay, no,
I don't know about that"
That's is the level of
absurd that JK Rowling
would bring to the table.
- I wish that was canon.
(laughter)
- I actually wish that was canon.
- I mean, it's not any more ridiculous
than like taking a shit and
making it disappear with magic.
- But I also, I love that,
I also think that's amazing.
Why wasn't that in the movie?
- I want like sometimes,
sometimes like I think
sometimes as an author
and as a consumer, you've got to,
you got to think sometimes, at what point
is there too much detail
in world creation?
- Yeah, that's true.
- That's the exact point
when there's too much fucking detail.
- There's too much fucking detail.
- I just loved that JK
Rowling thought about this
after the fact, "That's
a neat little fact"
I will let everyone
know, "Siri open Twitter"
- I would like to teach you
guys about the information
about the teleporting fecal matter.
- This also makes me
wonder, was it just like,
were they just fucking fascinated
when they first saw a
toilet in the human world.
They're like, holy, you have
a room dedicated for shitting.
That's just amazing, you know?
Do they wipe?
(laughter)
- Does that get teleported as well?
- No.
It doesn't get teleported,
I believe in like the,
do they get teleported?
- Does every single,
by that sense, you'd never need a shower
because every single thing
attached to your body,
including some, this is, you know-
- Well does it get teleported
while it's inside of you?
- No, no, I think what I
remember from the tweet
that she tweeted, I think you take a shit
and then they don't teleport it anywhere.
They just make it invisible, I think.
Magic away the evidence?
(laughter)
- Just magic away the evidence.
- What does that mean?
- That's so many
interpretation, oh my fucking-
- Magic away the evidence.
- I need a five page thesis,
no, I need like a 20 page thesis.
- I need like a six hour
video on the poop situation.
- You must have shit on
your ass though still.
Like it's not clean, you need
a bidet something or I assumed
as the spell get rid of that,
if so then why would you need
to ever shower because surely the smell
can also get rid of any
bodily fluids or odor
that you might have also, you know,
when they nut and if
they're inside of someone,
they don't wanna get them
pregnant, did they just like-
- Deletus!
(laughter)
- Do they just cum and then like-
- Fetus Deletus.
(laughter)
- Do they just, genuinely, do they cum
and they can just be like, cum
be gone like and it's gone?
(laughter)
- Oh my God.
- Are they able
to cast spells, if they,
okay, okay, I believe, right?
I'm on board, I'm on board
with the fact that you can,
you can spell away your own fluids, right?
In your own body, if you get your fluids
in someone else's body, can
your spell still get them away?
Does it, can you get rid of fluids
in other people's bodies?
- I just like to imagine like-
- Is that a thing?
- I want to say that
next time I nut.
(laughter)
- It's like baby, where's the condom?
Pulls out a wand, fetus deletus.
- Things you should never say after sex.
Fetus...
(laughter)
- Are we 10 years old here?
- I'm sorry.
- JK, can you please
make that cannon, please?
That's information I want to know
about the Harry Potter universe.
- Please make that canon.
- I don't care
about the disappearing shit.
- [Connor] I do.
- I care about what they
do to replace condoms
in the Harry Potter world.
- Oh, God.
I'm not gonna be able to get
that image out of my mind now.
Connor was having a rant
and I just like went off
in my own world.
- Just pointing the wand down.
"I got you, babe"
- Sorry.
What were we talking about?
- Yeah.
- Do you want
to repeat your rant?
- I was saying,
if you can get rid of the
fluids, excrement, that's yours,
if you nut in somebody else,
can you get rid of that fluids?
'Cause you have nut inside of them.
- I guess, so pull a fetus
deletus, then you got it.
- Right.
- Your blood is now gone.
You are dead, you know?
- Spinal fluid, gone.
Just collapse.
- This is a very
disgusting conversation
about bodily fluids.
- It's fascinating, it's fascinating.
- Thank you, thank you, JK Rowling.
- Thank you, JK.
- For letting our imagination
run wild.
- For asking
the important questions and answering
the important questions as well.
- I still can't get over the
fucking, like what was it?
Deleting the evidence with
magic or some of shit?
- Yeah, yeah, it was her own
words, vanish the evidence.
- Vanished the evidence with magic.
That's what I'm going to
say in court next time
when I commit a murder, your honor,
I vanished the evidence with magic.
Moving on from that.
- On other,
moving excrement, I've
been moving my stuff.
- You've been moving your shit.
- You've been moving period, right?
- Yes, moving house, oh
my gosh, took so long.
- Yeah.
- How's that
been going for you?
- Very long.
- I mean, people on Twitter were asking
and people coming into
my streams being like,
Connor's not streaming, what's happening?
- Everyone's like, why he hasn't
streamed for like 10 days.
I miss it, so kind of like
no subs when I come back.
So sad, gonna have to work
from the ground up again.
- You're pretty much
fully moved in, right?
Like you're out of your office?
- Yeah, I fully moved like a week ago
but then I went away for
like five days as well.
and also I didn't have any
furniture and then it all came
and it's taking up all of my living room.
So like building stuff
is such a nightmare.
- Yeah.
- I got like Jenga stuff
out of the way and then build it
but then it takes up a lot of room.
'Cause the boxes obviously
were tightly packed.
- Yeah, you've got to leave
the box to another room, right?
- Yeah, so it's like every time I feel
like I make any progress,
something else turns up
that I got to do and
I'm like for fuck sakes.
At least have a bed now.
- Oh, yeah?
- It's a nice bed as well.
- You got the koala bed?
- Yeah, I did.
- Are they like taking care
of all the fucking cardboard
that's been building up?
- Oh my God, yeah 'cause you know,
in the UK you could just,
you know, fill up your car,
drive down to the local recycling center
and chuck all the cardboard.
- Yeah.
- Pretty easy, really.
- But in Japan you can't do that.
You have to put it in your,
you have to recycle it
in your building.
- On a specific day.
- Actually you might be
able to take it somewhere
but I don't have a car.
- Yeah.
- And also I'm not renting a car
just to take cardboard but luckily,
the new place I moved into,
you can just put them out
at any time.
- Oh, that's good.
- And there's like a whole area
for trash downstairs.
- Oh, like an inside area?
- Yeah 'cause my previous
place it was put outside.
So you could only put it on
like Wednesday at 8:00 AM.
- Yeah, my current place
is like that as well.
- Yeah, I hated that 'cause I was like,
fuck dude, I got shit to do, man.
- See, my place though, it says you need
to take everything out before 8:00 AM.
(cross talk)
- Just do it the night before, not a fuck.
- At my place, they
don't come to pick it up
'til like 2:00 PM.
- Yeah.
- Oh yeah, they did that too, yeah.
- So I'm just like, I'll
just fucking take it out
in the morning then, whenever.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They used to, in my old
place, when I first moved in,
they were like, "You have
to wake up at 7:00 AM
to take out the trash" I'm like,
"I'm not waking up at 7:00 AM"
- Yeah.
- I'll stay up till like 4:00 AM
and do it, I'm not waking
up at seven, fuck off.
- Are you serious?
- I mean,
it's gotten me to like get a
good sleep schedule at least.
Like I wake up nice and
early in the morning
to get shit done.
- But that's not a good thing
to wake up to.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- "Oh yeah, wake up,
can't wait to go fucking take out
my fucking smelly garbage"
- You get used to it
after a while, honestly.
- But then yeah,
the new place is great, you
can just chuck it out anytime.
There's like, normally the more
modern apartment buildings,
you can just like go downstairs
and there'll be an area.
- Yeah, our old office had that.
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause it was a newer building.
- Yeah, the trash take out was super good.
It's basically like
that, it's like identical
but there's like a separate room
for like stinky trash, I guess?
(laughter)
I don't know, burnable.
- Uh-oh, stinky.
- All your food that's like burnable.
- Yeah.
- So there's just
like another room for that.
- I mean,
I guess that's good, right,
like because you know,
you don't have to, your
nose don't have to struggle
when you take cardboard out, right?
- It's so weird though, there's like,
my room has like this really like,
massive security camera
that points at the trash
and I'm guessing it's to stop you
from doing anything strange.
- Right.
- Or I like putting
trash that you shouldn't.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And there is literally
like black and white
tape all over this room.
Like it looks like a murder room
and I think it's on purpose to scare you.
- Right.
- To make you not feel
like it's okay to like-
- What would you do?
- I think trashing stuff you
shouldn't be trashing there.
- Because like trashing rules in Japan
are like weirdly specific.
- 'Cause burnable stuff,
right, in Japan, yeah, it's very specific.
So like plastic bottles,
can't go with plastic.
It has to very specifically
go with plastic bottles.
Yeah, there's a whole nother area
for that and cardboard
can't go with paper.
Paper is another thing.
- And that paper is burnables.
- Yeah, no, no, no, no,
in my place, it's not.
- Oh, really?
- It's recyclable.
- Yeah, paper is,
some places it's burnable but also depends
on the size of the paper,
if it's too small, it's not,
you can't put it in the thing,
it's really fucking weird.
There's so many rules and most
of them you have to follow.
- And all of these rules as well,
changes depending on where you are.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, you
can live in the same,
you can live in Tokyo but
every municipality in Tokyo
has a different rule and like, you know,
so also like batteries is very specific.
It can only be in a certain place.
So all this stuff is very confusing and,
and there should be no matter
where you live in Tokyo
or Cytomel Chiba or any of those places,
there should be an English guide.
They normally all have them.
- You should
get an English guide at the
town hall when you move in.
- Yeah, it's very confusing
because sometimes,
the material wasn't covered,
so like cardboard is good
but cardboard pizza boxes, no, no, no.
'Cause it's been greasy, so it can't go.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I
actually have an app that,
where if I type in a certain thing-
- Oh, really?
- Then it tells me
what day to take it out.
- That's pretty useful.
- So if I'm not sure then
I go to my app, I type in,
you know like, 'cause I
remember one time it was like,
there was like a specific
type of styrofoam.
It's not like the, it's not like the hard
like squeaky styrofoam, it's
more like a squishy styrofoam.
- Oh, the softer one?
- The squeaky one?
- Oh, the black one?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- The one that's layered?
- Like the squishy styrofoam.
So I was like, "Fuck, I
don't know what that is.
So I looked it up on the app and it was
on a completely different day.
I was like, oh thank God.
- Wait, really?
- I put that in burnable, bro.
- Well, I dunno, maybe my
municipal is different.
- Styrofoam is just the one
thing where I'm just like,
where does this go, I'm just like, uh?
- Styrofoam is burnable, right?
- Some types of styrofoam is burnable.
Other types is plastic.
- I thought it was recyclable.
Plastics, I've been putting it-
- See, it completely
changes where you are.
Sometimes it's all-
- I just put
like eight bags of that
shit in the burnable, fuck.
Sometimes it's all burnable,
sometimes it depends, yeah.
- You're gonna get a knock on your door,
like the police are going to come in
and just like, so...
- Excuse me,
are you the guys that threw
out all that styrofoam?
(laughter)
Just having a hunch.
- Imagine being the guy
that's just like threw
out all the burnables
in the wrong place.
- There's a lot of foreigners
in my building as well, so it's,
I don't feel like the odd one out,
I definitely felt like in my old building
it was for Japanese families.
- Well you were living
in an area that was very like, not-
- Oh yeah, dude.
- Not exactly
like gaijin friendly.
- We all were.
- 'Cause we all lived five
minutes away from each other.
- Yeah.
- Back in the day.
- And I lived even
further out than you guys.
So I definitely lived with
like all the families.
- A relatively older
building as well, right?
- Oh yeah, it was super old and it was
definitely a family building as well.
I don't know, I didn't
see anyone else there
who looked even remotely my age.
- Yeah.
- They were nice though, I never really
had any problems, except
I got a noise complaint
but I expected as much.
- Well, I mean,
if you're shouting at fucking 02:00 AM.
- It's one of those things that-
- It's probably a matter of time.
- When I first moved in, I would literally
walk around my own apartment
like metal gear solid.
Like I was so sick 'cause
I'd heard nightmare scenarios
about noise where I was just
tiptoeing around my apartment,
like at night because I genuinely
thought if I just walked
at a normal brisk pace, I
would get like shouted at
but you know, the months go
on and you start to realize,
you know, okay, okay.
- I can't help the clapping
of my ass cheeks being so loud.
- I'm so dummy thicc.
- Yeah, you're so dummy thicc.
- You know, then one
time I had friends over
who stayed over until five and
I never got a noise complaint
and then I was like oh,
okay and then you slowly
get more comfortable.
- You test the limit.
- Yeah because you know, and
then maybe something happened
where, all right, there's a deadline,
I have to record this thing, it's 2:00 AM
and they need it right now.
- Yeah.
- Okay, well I guess I'll do it.
I'll just scream one line and I'll do it
and then I'll also, I had to
record voice lines one time.
I just, I distinctly remember
we're full on shouting,
but this was like midday
but it was to the point
where I was, this is shouting so loud
and so aggressively that
I would totally understand
if the police were called in any scenario.
- Sounded like a murder was happening.
Literally, even a murderer
wouldn't have done it
with such conviction the way I did.
So I was, I did that and that definitely
made me more confident.
- Right.
- So it's one of those
things where it just built up
and then I started streaming
and I started streaming later
and later and later and then
I started screaming louder
and louder and then eventually
I got a noise complaint,
which is totally 'cause I
think it was one where I was
totally screaming at 4:00 AM,
which I totally understood.
I just assumed the people below me
because this was a four bedroom.
I just assumed they were sleeping
in a totally different
room and they were so old
that nothing would wake them up.
- That's the thing, yeah.
- I was hoping
that they were that kind of
old people where they were not
getting up for anything.
- Yeah, that's the thing.
Sometimes like, you get
lucky because like the room
that if you, especially if
you have multiple rooms,
the room that you screamed the loudest in,
is nowhere near where the
person downstairs is sleeping.
- Yeah, it's always, it's mostly like,
where is the bedroom located
and am I making a lot of noise
where their bedroom is located?
'Cause anywhere else I feel
like it's more understanding
about it, but it's always the bedroom
and I think like I really lucked out
with the apartment I had before.
'Cause I've never got a noise complaint.
- You're very lucky, I don't
know how you've done that.
- I feel like I definitely should,
like I fucking limit tested that thing.
- We've had parties at
your house at 5:00 AM.
- We've had very loud parties
at 5:00 AM on a Saturday.
So we weren't being complete assholes.
- It doesn't matter to the old people.
- In Japan, that is
not acceptable anywhere
but it's, yeah, I fucking
limit broke that shit
and I didn't get a noise complaint.
I'm very, very surprised.
- Saturdays,
it doesn't matter what
day of the week it is
to an old person, like 'cause
like the cops aren't going
to be like, all right,
we got a noise complaint
and you'd be like, it's Saturday.
- License to party.
- Yeah.
- It's Saturday.
- Cop's like,
"Understandable, have a nice day"
- I just feel like I
lucked out because I feel
like I had neighbors who had
like a mutual understanding
'cause I feel like I've
had the only neighbor
that I know of, of anyone living in Japan
that was like really fucking noisy,
like they would have arguments
all the time and it wasn't
just like a Japanese argument,
it was full on shouting, sometimes it was
the most un-Japanese Japanese
argument I've ever heard,
right?
- Very dramatic.
- And I'm just like, if you make noise,
then you know, I'm going
to make noise as well.
- Mutual understanding.
- Yeah, mutual understanding.
It's a symbiotic relationship, you know.
- I mean, there were, I
always very, you know,
even if I was making noise, I would be,
if they're having a party once a month.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's once a month.
I can live with that,
it's not like I have like,
I dunno like a bonsai tree
that's sensitive to noise
or something in my
apartment that shits itself
if it hears two decibels,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- I think it's okay.
I think that's why I
wouldn't really call the cops
but Japanese people
have no chill with that
and they just immediately call the cops.
- Well no, because to them it's like,
"Why are you being so loud at home
when you could just go
to an (speaking Japanese)
and go out in town and have
fun?" and I'm like, I would,
if everything doesn't close at 8:00 PM
and alcohol can't be served.
- Yeah.
One of the things that's
been so, taking so long
in my new places that
my office I've actually
like gone through the
whole effort of like trying
to sound treat it to
the best of my ability
as much as you can 'cause the best way
to sound proof a room used to do it
while they're building the God damn room
but I've had to do it in post.
- Yeah.
- And it's been a nightmare.
I've had to put like two
layers of stuff on my wall
and then I still haven't done it all yet.
So like two layers of fabric
that I've attached to the wall
and then I'm doing the third,
which is that like sound foam
because you know, YouTubers
just put like four pieces
and it's like, it's soundproof,
my room and it's like,
that is not even remotely soundproof.
- I like the rooms where it's
like one piece over here,
another piece over here.
- It's just one piece
behind where they're
sitting and then like,
my job here is done.
- Soundproofed.
- My living looks super weird right now
'cause it's just all
like every single wall
is like a black plastic rubber.
- Yeah.
- But it works,
you can't really hear me--
- Immediately the echo's gone?
- Yeah, and so I put a
layer of the rubber stuff
down as well and then I
put noise reducing carpet
on top of it.
So like you can jump in my
room, neighbors ain't going
to hear shit downstairs.
- Yeah.
I actually just finished
laying down carpet in my office
as well, like finally.
- Yeah.
'Cause I was talking to
Jerry while I was doing it.
Jerry was like, that
sounds like a good idea.
- Yeah, so I decided to do that in my room
'cause my room was like
super fucking echo-y.
'Cause I have like wooden floors.
- Yeah, it helps so much, yeah.
- Immediately once I put
up, before I even started
putting up the sound foam
immediately with the carpet,
it's like, 80% of the echo just gone.
- Yeah, every single wall you do makes it,
it gets better results.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's not since I moved to Japan
that I'm just like, man, carpets
look good, I miss carpets.
'Cause like we had to carpets in England.
Like you didn't have, like
you didn't have a house,
you never had a house in
England that had wooden floors,
right 'cause it's not
good for noise, not noise,
like a heat installation, right?
- We had them.
- Really?
- No living room was wooden
but upstairs was carpet.
- Yeah, so our house was like
half wooden, half carpet.
- In like your rooms, you'd
have carpet and I'm like,
I didn't know how much I missed that
until I moved to Asia
where everything here
is wooden floors.
- We had like fitted carpet
in Europe, I think why that they come in
and they specially like get the right size
and they fit it all professionally
but in Japan they always use the square,
like just pick up and go kind of things.
- Yeah, the post carpet.
- They just,
in Japan, like a lot of
the carpets are just like,
you'll see them everywhere,
they're just like these-
- Like cubes.
- Yeah.
We have it here.
- Like squares.
- Yeah, they're everywhere,
like they're just like squares,
you plunk them down and
then you just cut them
around the edges, like
hand cut it to my room.
It looks really fucking good but I spent
like a whole fucking day doing them.
- Yeah, I did too, because
my room's not square.
It's like weird fucking shapes.
I'm like, fuck sakes.
- Yeah and cutting the corners
and stuff in a pain in the ass.
- So look it looks good from a distance
but when you get down on the floor,
you see how much of a shit job I did.
- 'Cause it's hard, man, it's hard.
- I'm very proud of it, I've
been DIYing for like two days
and it look good, it looks amazing
and when everything's set
up, it should be good.
- That'll be me in like two months.
'Cause I think I'm the
last one to move out.
- I'm planning to have a whole
wall of just JoJo posters.
- Oh nice.
- Of course.
- That'll be like-
- Didn't you have that
in your old place?
- No, no.
Literally, before you could see the walls.
I was going to make it like
literally like 90% of the wall
is just Jojo posters.
- Isn't it already?
- No but like, they had
gaps, they had gaps.
I don't want gaps, I
want it to be literally-
- Side by side by side.
- The wall
is made out of JoJo.
- The wall is JoJo.
The floor is JoJo.
- But like,
how good of a shot would it be?
It's like just behind me,
it's literally just Jojo.
That's so bad ass.
- The wall is JoJo.
- So like, the way I attached
it to the wall was like,
I wasn't sure if it would,
it would like be able
to hold the posters
'cause this rubber stuff
that I got to prevent
sound is fucking heavy.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- You bought a roll as well, right?
- Yeah, it is, it's massive.
- Like, what is it?
10 meters, it's a 10 meter roll.
- By like one meter wide, I think.
- One meter wide, 10 meters
long and it's 20 kilograms
and it is so fucking heavy.
- You put that on your wall?
- Yeah, exactly, right?
- How?
- With great difficulty and so
I was concerned, I was like,
the way I attached to it, I was like,
I wonder if it will stay if
I then put posters on it.
So before I left for my
trip, I attached the posters
and I was like, hopefully
when I come back,
my wall will be intact
and luckily it's intact.
- It's intact, yeah.
- Should be fine
but the poster frames I
have are extremely light.
They're like the lightest
poster frames I could find.
- Oh yeah, then you should be all right.
- Should be fine,
- Should be fine.
- Hopefully, be really awkward
if I'm streaming one day and my whole wall
just fucking comes down.
- I feel like the big test
is going to be in summer,
right or next summer.
- I'm just going to leave
my AC on all the time.
I'm not risking it.
- Really, all the time?
- That's what I did in my
current place, because you know,
the electricity bill, right,
if you have, I had like what,
like 20 grand of computer
equipment in my room
and filming equipment,
the AC bill to have it
running all the time is what like
maybe an extra 200, 300
bucks for the whole summer?
- Well, yeah, it depends on
how long you have it on for,
I guess.
- So for the summer period,
just to leave it on, I'll pay that much
just to have my equipment be fine.
- Yeah, that's true.
- Humidity
fucks your microphones and
cameras and PC equipment.
I would rather just have
the whole room AC'ed 24/7.
- Yeah, I'm thinking to
invest in a dehumidifier
just to put around my-.
- Just get a dehumidifier.
Yeah.
- I have a dehumidifier in my-
- As like a Southeast
Asian, I'm just like,
part of my soul is dying when
I hear AC is on 24/7, man.
- No, no, you can just
put the AC on dehumidify.
There's a setting for dehumidify.
- Yeah, that's true.
- So I'll leave it on that.
- Okay, okay, okay, what happens if the,
when the AC inevitably breaks?
- It's a good AC, it's not breaking.
- Didn't your AC break?
- Yeah.
One of the other AC is broken.
- So what's to say it
won's happen in your room?
- The other one for two years was fine.
I'll deal with it when it breaks.
It'll be down for like three days at most.
It's fine.
- Right, right.
- 'Cause like I grew up with
like, I grew up with my parents
beating into me, that just like, "Look,
the world could be on
fucking fire right now
but you're not telling on that
AC unless you like really,
really need to"
- Also, I'm probably gonna
get a bunch of comments being like,
Connor's wasting so much electricity.
He's not in the room"
and I'm like, "No, no,
I'm saving the money for
not replacing the equipment"
- He's saving the equipment.
- Like the devil
could be raising hell
right outside a window
and you're not turning on the AC.
- No, fuck that, sometimes
I go to my mate's house
in summer it's fucking roasting,
I'm like, "Why are you like this?
Why do you hate yourself?"
- I mean, the summer,
it's like the devil came back from hell
and planted his ass crack on the earth.
- It's like, if you can withstand that
and you can live in a sauna, that's fine.
I'm not going to judge
you, you can live in that.
Don't come to my fucking house
and tell me to turn my AC off.
I didn't choose to live a life like this.
I didn't want to live on hard mode.
I know I don't need to, I'm not going to.
Fuck off, don't come to
my house and tell me that.
- I'm going to do exactly that
next time I come to your house.
- I'm going to go mom
mode and just be like,
"I can't believe you're
wasting all this electricity"
- "Think of the electricity bill, Connor"
- I couldn't care less, you know.
- "Think of the electricity bill, my God"
- Listen, I've lived like that,
I don't need to live like that.
I make good money now, I don't
need to worry about that.
- I just feel sorry for your
AC, man, it's just like,
oh, I'm getting a break sometime, right?
- In the new place as well they installed,
like those industrial ones,
you have them as well.
- Yeah, built into the ceiling.
- Right, right, right.
- Looks pretty modern.
Really nice.
- Yeah.
Lifesaver that.
- It's beautiful.
- Yeah.
- I just noticed that this AC is not on
and it's already cold.
- Yeah, I mean,
it's thankfully cooled down this week.
Are we still technically in summer?
I don't even know
- We are technically
in summer, this like
past week we've had this
like rain, this torrential
rain from this like cold front
coming in from Hokkaido.
and there's been light flood warnings
in like the greater Tokyo area
and I'm just like, oh man,
this typhoon season is really fucking off.
I looked at the news,
it's not even typhoon.
- No, no, it's not a typhoon, no.
- It's just rain, and I'm like,
how is it raining more
than a typhoon right now?
- Just cause like seasons in
Japan just don't make sense
to me, like you wake up one day
and then Japan just decided,
okay, summer's over, we're
in the next season now.
- It's snowing now.
- Yeah, winter's over,
we're in the next season,
there is no fucking
transition period.
You wake up one day and you
suddenly go from like dying
in the heat to like, oh
you got to wear trousers
and long shirts now and long sleeves.
- The statement of
"Japan has four seasons"
is the biggest lie of the century.
- No.
- It does not.
- It has two seasons cot, cold or hot.
- Cot.
- Cold or hot.
That's the only two seasons,
there is no in between.
- You know how you go to that
one place and someone's like,
oh you don't like the weather?
Just wait five minutes, ha
ha ha ha, in Japan it's like,
you don't like the season,
just wait a few days
and it'll change.
- Just leave the country.
- Don't put your jacket
away, you're going to need it
in about three days, guaranteed.
- And then there's England, right?
Where I never know what the
appropriate way to dress is
in England, like if it's summer,
do I wear a long sleeve still?
Still do I wear short
sleeves, do I wear shorts?
Do I bring a coat with me, I just like,
England is the place where
it's always acceptable
to bring a coat just in case.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I don't, what am I supposed to pack?
We're going to England, I
don't know what to wear.
- I genuinely don't.
- Do I, what I have to wear?
Can I get away with shirts, do I have to-
- Do I need to bring the drip?
- I don't know, how much
drip do I gotta bring?
- How much drip, is drip
acceptable in the UK?
- How much, am I allowed to be drip?
- Am I allowed to be drip?
(laughter)
- Am I allowed to be drip in the UK?
(Connor laughs)
- I don't know.
- Yeah 'cause like,
it's just one place where I go outside
and I'm just like, should
I bring a coat with me?
And the answer is always yes.
- Yeah.
You can never really go
wrong with bringing a coat
in the UK, in Japan, I
feel like a fucking clown
when I bring a coat in the summer.
- Well I mean, especially
this time of year.
Yeah, have you noticed though that like
what you wear in the UK
is completely different
to what you would normally wear here?
Like in terms of like sense of fashion?
Because I feel like,
at least with me, like-
- [Connor] Sometimes.
- I wouldn't dress
like this in Australia, for instance.
- Why?
- I don't know
because I feel that like,
just in general, just,
I don't know, maybe it's
just the area that I live in
but like Japan, I feel
has definitely like,
put in like a different
sense of fashion into me
than back in Australia, like it,
to me in Australia fashion
was t-shirt, shorts, sandals.
- Yeah, I mean that's Australia, right?
I mean that was like-
- Isn't that
the national motto of Australia?
- It's like, you'd feel fancy
if you wore a pair of jeans,
you know, it's like that level, right?
But here it's like, I dunno, I feel weird
going out with t-shirts,
shorts and sandals.
- I mean, I think, it's
just living in a country
that's permanently in summer, right?
Because that's kind of me in Thailand
where if I'm not wearing
t-shirts, shorts and sandals,
something special is happening,
like, so it's like this,
like in England, you look
for any opportunity you can
to wear shorts, in Thailand, you look
for any opportunity you can to
wear jeans and long sleeves.
- I want to wear jeans, I don't
really like wearing shorts.
I don't really feel comfortable in them.
- Why?
- I don't know.
- You don't like exposing your legs?
- Maybe I haven't found the right pair.
Yes, don't you sit on, I feel like I'm-
- Well, how short of shorts
are you wearing, though?
- No, reasonably sized, reasonably sized.
- Right, right, right, right.
- I feel like I can't enjoy
every surface, you know
when you just sit down
on some things like wearing shorts,
I don't like how my skin
touches this, geeze.
- What about like three quarter pants?
- Oh, those are a bit
strange, aren't they?
- Yeah, see, like it's
weird, like something
like three quarter pants
is completely normal here
but I would feel super fucking weird
if I wore three quarter pants
in Australia and it's not
because of like the weather.
It's just because like, I
wouldn't see anyone in Australia
just fashion wise wearing
three quarter pants.
- I just don't think
shorts look very good.
Like no, no, no, okay-
- No one looks good in shorts.
- No look-
- Every Australian
is offended.
- No one looks better
in shorts than they would
wearing like jeans or something.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay because like,
it's sunny outside, okay,
so people can look good
on the beach or whatever
in shorts or whatever.
Anytime you go inside, you
sit down in the restaurant,
you look like a fucking
clown, there is no exception
to not looking like a
clown when you go inside
and you're wearing
shorts, like there's like,
I'm watching like the Trash
Tastes off the dark screen
and I'm just like, fucking
hell, our legs look so ugly.
(laughter)
- It's just knees on knees on knees.
- And there's just so many knees, man.
- Too much skin going on.
- And if it's just
like the three quarter
pants, well we just like,
at that point you just
have commitment issues.
Just commit to shorts or commit to jeans.
Like please come on, just-
- Yeah.
- I think like, being from the UK,
I feel like fashion was
never a high priority.
Especially in Wales.
- Well, yeah
and I feel in the same way
with Australia as well.
Like I feel just, I
never even thought about
what I was wearing in Australia
because I look around me and I'm like,
I don't really see anyone
who's like fashionable.
- People have so much fucking drip here.
It's insane.
- Yeah, the drip here-
- People will just be going to work
and they'll be dressed
like a fucking model.
It's nuts.
- And I feel
that's why I almost, not so much pressured
but I guess I kind of, that
made me look at myself,
reflect on myself
- Yeah.
I feel like I have to
step up my game, bro.
- I mean, I feel like London
was pretty fashionable.
- No, everyone dresses the same, I feel.
- Really?
- Everyone dresses the same,
I feel in London.
- I feel like,
I would say that even
maybe people in London
have even more drip than
people here in Tokyo.
That's my genuine
opinion, you see someone-
- You have such shit takes (laughs)
- Why can we not agree over
fucking London? (laughs)
You the architecture, I fucking hated it.
I think London's a fashionable city.
- You loo at like a fucking
Primark or anything,
the models, everyone
fucking dresses the same.
- What are you fucking talking about?
Primark slaps, like, for what you get,
for the price, Primark
fashion is fucking amazing.
- Of course, for fucking child labor,
you can get some good clothes, you know.
- Primark's a great place.
- I remember one time,
I bought 10 t-shirts for
eight pounds in Primark
and I thought, fucking
hell, who made a deal
with the devil here, why was
this price able to go through?
- I've bought one thing at Primark
and it was a pair of eight
Sonic the Hedgehog socks
for five pounds.
- That's overpriced.
What the fuck, you got mugged off.
They're like one pound for eight socks.
- Yeah but I'm like-
- I bought a whole suit
from Primark for like
30 quid and I'm like,
what the fuck, what happened?
- I mean,
it looked decent, right, it looked decent.
- That's the problem, it looked good.
(laughter)
- What do you mean, that's the problem?
- I think now I'm like,
you know, we paid what?
Like fucking 70 pounds for a
t-shirt, no $70 for t-shirt,
so what, 40 pounds for a
t-shirt, I now feel that,
you know, maybe it's because
I have more money now.
Maybe it's because I'm
not, I'm doing much better
for myself, I feel that, oh,
I think I would rather pay 30,
$40 for a very good
t-shirt as opposed to $8
for 10 t-shirts.
- Yeah.
- Yeah but like, that's the thing,
the biggest thing I've noticed-
- I just think something's gone wrong.
- No, I feel like the biggest difference
since moving to Japan
is that there were just
more affordable options in high street
in high streets in the UK and that-
- How much affordable is like,
we're cutting some severe
human rights corners here.
- Well, I'm like, no, this
is like, I mean, that's going
to a different topic,
we're talking about drip,
right, people having drip, I feel like,
especially in London, a lot
of people have the drip.
- Drip comes with a cost, guys.
With the blood,
- Of course.
Of course, it comes with the cost.
- The poor children.
- But like,
you look here and basically like,
it's just Uniqlo here and Uniqlo
and like a few other places here
but in England you just
have a lot of choices
and there is like no
equivalent to Primark,
I think worldwide, there's been nowhere
in the world I've gone
to, that is a really,
really cheap place to find
clothes and just looks as good
as Primark, I'm just, I
will happily still shop
at Primark now, I think Primark clothes
are like underrated
just because it's cheap,
but you look at Primark clothes
and you could easily sell that for like-
- I just always walk out
with like five t-shirts
I'm never going to wear because
I thought they looked good
in the store, 'cause it's so cheap
'cause you're like, I'll have five.
- That's literally me at Uniqlos.
- It's literally like the
Primark is the equivalent
of going to an all you can
eat buffet at a restaurant.
Right, you're just like, maybe I feel like
having an Indian curry and a pizza
at the same time, you know?
- Sick hearing now.
I don't wanna hear that combination.
- But it's just like you do it
because you're just like, well,
I just got so much choice.
I just, maybe we'll have
a bit of Mexican as well
and a bit of Chinese and it's just,
and it's an absolute fucking mess.
- My fight or flight response
is kicking in just hearing that.
- And then you shit yourself violently
and then you wipe it away
with magic, you know?
- Fine, Garnt.
- Bring it back.
- You can have it, yeah, sure, drip, yeah.
(Garnt laughs)
- Wait, so are you saying Primark is drip?
- I'm not saying Primark is drip.
- Okay, I just had to make sure.
- I'm saying Primark is
affordable drip, it doesn't look-
- That's an oxymoron.
- Why, why?
- I don't know, like, what is drip?
- Expensive clothes, just-
- Drip is like-
- I thought it was just
clothes that look good.
- Yeah but it's kind of like
the Hypebeast stuff as well.
- Oh fuck off, fuck off,
drip, that just means
that good drip, you know, you
have to buy brand name shit.
- That's kind of what it was.
- Usually.
- That's what it was.
- That's usually,
that what is was originally.
- It's kind of
been developed a bit more
now and kind of hijacked
to be more of just good clothes.
- Yeah, just fashionable clothing, right?
- Just fashionable clothing,
that's what I, that's what,
when I heard drip, that's
what I always thought it was,
you know, sometimes brand name clothes.
- That's what a person would think.
- Fuck off, fuck off.
- That's what someone
who doesn't wear drip would say.
(laughter)
- Are you telling me that
every brand name's stuff
looks good, there are equally
as many brand name stuff
that I'm just like, this
looks like absolute dog turd
and if I see someone wearing that,
I'm going to think they have zero drip.
You can wear a Louis, that
could be Louis Vuitton
and I could think it looks like shit.
- Yeah, I get that but at
the same time, you know,
if I was like walking down the
strip, flaunting off my drip,
right and then someone
came up to me and was like,
"That drip's sick, where'd you get that?"
I wouldn't like be like, Primark.
I'm not going to say that.
- I'll fucking say that.
If it looks good, who
the fuck gives a shit?
If it looks like, if you
look like you have drip,
then you have drip, I couldn't
matter where it comes from.
It doesn't matter, it doesn't
matter where he comes from.
- Garnt, fighting for the everyday man.
- I copped this piece from Walmart.
- This is from The Gap.
- Yeah, Tarjay.
- I mean, fashion is like the
biggest fucking scam there is.
Are you saying to me-
- I don't know.
I just want to, I just want to say,
I don't feel bad about buying now.
I just want something that lasts as well.
- I'm obviously not
going to like, you know,
fucking go to every high-end place
and buy like $500 t-shirts
or something like that.
- I've bought so many
t-shirts from Primark
that I sweat in once and it
is like permanently stained.
I can not get those orange
pits out to save my life.
- I mean, that's why you
buy five of them, right?
- Well, that's the problem is I feel bad
about buying a shirt
that I bin immediately
after I have one bad summer or I go
to one Indian restaurant.
- Like why buy five shirts?
- I mean, I mean, the fabric is like,
definitely low quality fabric, right?
- See, that's the problem,
I don't want to buy a shirt
that I feel like I can only get two,
three good wears out of.
- Yeah, exactly.
- That's what you pay for when
you pay for cheap fabrics.
- That's what I'm saying, like,
why don't you use that money to just
buy one good quality one
that'll last you and is more-
- Yeah, Garnt, I see you
hating the environment.
Fuck you with your t-shirts.
- What has that
got to do with drip, though?
- Because-
- If you look good, you look
good, I'm just fucking saying.
- Fuck the planet, fuck those little kids
making those shirts, you got
drip at affordable price.
- I mean, you've just been brainwashed
by the fashion industry
to say this looks good
because it's expensive and
has a brand's name, you know?
- No, I also think that you
pay for the quality material
that lasts a while.
- Yeah, I agree.
- The quality material
doesn't always equate.
- Like Glam, right?
- We buy those Glam shirts
right they're, like 60 bucks a t-shirt.
- Sometimes 80 bucks.
- I have got
some serious mileage out of those shirts.
- Yeah.
- No, so I'm not arguing-
- And that shit's dripy.
- Yeah, dude.
- If people are like,
oh, it's $60 a t-shirt.
Bro, how many of those
t-shirts have you bought
from like Primark and shit
that like are fucking garbage
after like five washes.
- I'm not arguing that
but I'm arguing that you
can buy good quality,
good looking stuff for a
lot cheaper than you can get
for Glam and everything like that.
- I just think fast fashion is
like bad for the environment.
It's just bad in general,
I just think you should
buy shirts that-
- Just buy something
that lasts.
- Buy something that lasts.
- He's saying that he, I mean,
you saying that a t-shirt
should always be like $30,
minimum, 30, $50 dollars minimum?
- It's not so much about the price for me.
It's about like what it's made of, right?
And like if it'll last.
- I have so many t-shirts
that I don't wear because I
just have too many t-shirts
because a lot of them, I would just buy
because they were cheap.
- Yeah.
I would never end up wearing them.
I would always wear the nicer
shirts that I could clean-
- Didn't you also say that you just,
you don't wash jeans,
you just throw them away
and buy new ones?
- I would wear a pair
of jeans for like two years
until they are fucked.
I wear the same pair of
jeans over and over again.
- You don't wash your jeans?
- I will,
I would rarely wash them,
you don't need to wash jeans.
- Why are we talking
about dripping advice?
(off camera laughter)
- You don't need to wash jeans.
- We are taking drip advice from this guy.
- We're taking drip advice from a guy
who doesn't wash his jeans.
- Hey, Google.
- I'm sorry, who is the
peasant here, Connor?
I'm sorry, who is the
fucking peasant here?
- Do you need to wash jeans?
- Look, I will argue right,
that yes, like you could
buy a $10 shirt, right?
From Primark or something
and you can, you know,
you can layer with something cheap
and you can make it look
good but what I'm saying
is the average Primark buyer-
- You should never
wash a pair of jeans is one of the CEO
of a jean company says.
- The CEO of a jean company?
- Particularly, if it's
a good quality jean.
- Said Michael Jean, the creator of jeans.
- If it's a good quality jean,
you don't need to wash it.
- I will-
- You just spot wash
that shit, you got to stain,
just get rid of the stain.
- I do not know enough about this topic.
- Genuinely, genuinely, you don't need to-
- To be fair.
- I don't trust your-
(laughter)
I'm just saying, I don't
know enough about this topic.
- Smell my jeans, Garnt, smell my jeans.
- Get that shit out of my face, man.
Get that out of my face.
- They smell fresh, bro.
- That's that musky shit.
- I've been sweating in these.
They smell good, give them a sniff.
- That's just, that is
drip, that's dripping
with your fucking sweat, Connor.
Is that what you're talking
about when you mean drip?
- Bro, there's some stains here
that I should got to spot clean off.
- Garnt, do you know how many people
would pay for that experience?
- Smell my jeans, bro.
- Smell Connor's jeans.
- Give them a sniff.
- Get that shit
out of my face, man.
- Smell his jeans.
Smell it.
- Smells good.
- Yeah?
- Yeah, man, give them a wiff.
- Would you say that after
wearing them in summer?
No.
- I don't like
washing my jeans because,
and frankly as well,
I don't like how they feel
after you do wash them.
They feel horrible the
first time you wear them
after you wash jeans,
they feel all like crinkly
and you got to wear them back
in again, I don't like that.
- Well, I mean that's if you
do like a cold wash though.
- No, no, warm wash.
- If you do a warm wash
where it doesn't like
shrink, then it's fine.
- No, it still does it.
- Really?
You're buying the cheap jeans, then.
- I'm just--
No, no, no, Uniqlo's finest.
(laughter)
- I mean, to be fair,
Uniqlo does do good jeans.
- I'm just saying you don't,
you don't need wash jeans.
- I mean-
- I just,
I wear the same pair of jeans.
Like I don't have multiple, I
only have one pair of jeans.
When it breaks, I just buy a new one.
When it gets holes, buy a new one.
When it's, a stain's too
deep, I get a new one.
That's is pretty much all I do.
- Have you considered like, you know
like removing the color from your shirts.
- I want my jeans to look fresh.
- Just soft wash everything.
- Yeah.
- You don't need to wash jeans.
- Well, there you go,
the drip king has spoken.
You don't need to wash jeans.
- It's the King of Drip.
- I mean, I just think
fashion is bullshit.
Don't worry about how much you spend.
I mean, it's-
- Glad to know
that you have Trash Taste, Garnt.
- I mean like, okay, like,
the one thing I never got,
for example was Supreme, right?
- Okay, that's a different caliber.
- What you mean that's
a different caliber?
It all comes down to drip, right?
- No, no like Supreme-
- That's different.
- How is it, it's literally a brand name
that's expensive as fuck.
- No, that's not,
that's not a brand, that's a meme.
- Yeah, that's a man.
- Yeah, Supreme is a fucking,
at this point-
- It's not a meme.
- They made a crow bar, no one
is going around being like,
this posh.
- They made a brick.
- This is not a company
that is in the business
of making extremely high quality stuff.
It's in the business
of making scarce stuff.
- To this point-
- At this point, it is a meme
but it wasn't always a meme, if you go
to any Asian country back when
it was like in their prime
and people had Supreme on
just because it was expensive
and it was one of the biggest
brand names at that point.
- It wasn't like good quality.
- It wasn't good quality,
Supreme was a skate brand.
- Supreme isn't like a daily wear brand.
- Like skateboarders used to wear,
that was like made for skateboarding.
- Yeah but for the longest
time, that was drip.
That was drip, right?
- No.
- You can't argue with me, you can't.
- There hasn't been a
single, like in my opinion,
there hasn't been a single
piece of Supreme shirts
or anything where I was like, that's drip.
- I feel like the old
definition of drip was brand.
Was brand.
- Yeah.
Brands like Gucci, Louis Vuitton,
all that kind of stuff.
- But I feel like now,
because it's been adopted so much
and used so much over the last few months,
it does just mean looking good.
- Yeah and I'm just saying, you don't need
to fucking buy expensive
stuff or brand name stuff
to have drip, you don't.
- No, you don't
You also shouldn't be
buying 10 t-shirts for $5.
- You also shouldn't be
wearing a Primark shirt
and calling it drip.
- Yeah.
- I think you can call it a drip.
I'm just saying if you layer it right.
- Yeah, okay, if you layer it right
but there isn't a single
person going to Primark
and being like, time to buy some drip.
No one goes to Primark thinking that.
- Also, if you spend $30 t-shirt right?
I think that's a worthwhile investment.
You're wearing this shit every day.
- I mean, if it looks good.
- That $30 t-shirt
is going to last you longer
than those three 10 pound shirt.
- Yeah, 100%.
- Yeah, probably.
Like all I'm not saying
don't buy $30 t-shirts
if it looks, all I'm
saying is if it looks good,
it looks good, doesn't
matter about the price.
Doesn't matter about
the fucking brand name.
Like it's all a scam, anyway because-
- I think at that point, it
literally just comes to like,
that person's personal preference of like,
do they consider this drip or no?
- I'm just saying, I
think we're fucking dumb.
I think we're just really fucking dumb.
(laughter)
- What the fuck does that mean?
- Don't put words in my mouth.
- I think this is a shit debate.
- Like three people who
have no idea in fashion
being like, what is drip?
- I feel
like I'm arguing the best way
to perform open heart surgery.
I feel like I'm really not
qualified to be discussing this.
- Obviously, wearing Supreme.
- Not none of us are
but wait, when are we ever qualified
to talk about the things we-
- We're never qualified
to talk about shit we argue about.
- Three weaves discuss drip,
we're possibly the three least
qualified people to talk about drip.
That doesn't mean I'm not going to argue.
- That's Trash Taste.
- You know who do
has drip though, our patrons.
- They do, they do.
- Because they are dripping the funds
into the picture.
- Man, this guy is dripping,
man, he probably owns 10 Supreme.
- Look at these Hypebeasts right here.
Look at all of them, amazing, hey,
if you'd like to join the Hypebeast gang,
AKA our Patreon, then go to our Patreon,
patron.com/trash taste,
also follow us on Twitter.
Send us your names on the
sub and if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify, but yeah,
what the was this episode even about?
- This was a very long episode.
How long have we been recording for?
- We talked about scams.
- Fuck me.
- We talked about scams,
Harry Potter shit and drip.
- And Toy Story.
- And Toy Story and we somehow
talked about Eva as well.
I completely forgot.
- And Eva as well.
- We forgot that we just talked about Eva.
- Shinji is BoJack Horseman.
- Shinji is BoJack.
Shits disappear in Harry Potter
and you can buy drip from Primark.
That's three things you
should take out of it.
- Hagrid fists.
- All right, bye guys.
- Bye.
(upbeat music)